This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. June 5, 1944, General Dwight D. Eisenhower, Supreme Commander of Allied Forces, had driven unannounced to the Greenham Common Air Force Base in the United Kingdom. Paratroopers of the 101st Airborne Division were preparing for a historic jump. General Eisenhower wanted to boost morale. The soldiers knew they were on a mission, but they didn't yet know the scale. The general eased their fears with a confident demeanor and friendly small talk.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。1944年6月5日，盟军最高统帅德怀特·D·艾森豪威尔将军在未事先通知的情况下，驱车前往英国格林汉姆公用空军基地。第101空降师的伞兵们正在为一次历史性的跳伞做准备。艾森豪威尔将军想要鼓舞士气。士兵们知道他们肩负着使命，但还不知道任务的规模。将军以自信的风度和友好的闲谈缓解了他们的恐惧。
Where are you from? he asked one lieutenant. Michigan? Spectacular fishing there, Eisenhower said. He was about to release a short and blunt one-page memo, telling troops that they were on a great crusade to liberate Europe. He ordered them to accept nothing less than full victory. But that evening, as he made his way back home, the general confided in his driver,
“你是哪里人？”他问一位中尉。“密歇根州？那里的钓鱼很棒，”艾森豪威尔说。他即将发布一份简短而直率的单页备忘录，告诉部队他们正在进行一场解放欧洲的伟大十字军东征。他命令他们必须取得全面胜利，不接受任何妥协。但那天晚上，当他回到住处时，将军向他的司机吐露了心声，
I hope to God I'm right. The weather forecasts were uncertain and a slight change could lead to failure. Eisenhower returned to his cottage and wrote a message that no one was supposed to see, a statement taking full responsibility if D-Day failed. Our landings have failed to gain a satisfactory foothold and I have withdrawn the troops, he wrote.
“我向上帝祈祷我是对的。”天气预报很不确定，一点点变化都可能导致失败。艾森豪威尔回到他的小屋，写下了一份本不该被任何人看到的声明，如果诺曼底登陆失败，他将承担全部责任。他写道：“我们的登陆未能获得令人满意的立足点，我已经撤回了部队。”
If any blame or fault attaches to the attempt, it is mine alone. He underlined those final words for emphasis and tucked the note into his wallet. He never needed it. Under the command of General Eisenhower, Allied naval forces, supported by strong air forces, began landing Allied armies this morning on the northern coast of France. A few days later, a now iconic photo was published in newspapers. Ike, surrounded by those American paratroopers, he leans in, tall and eagle-eyed.
“如果这次尝试有任何过失或责任，那全归我一人。”他为了强调而划线标出了最后几个字，并将这张纸条塞进钱包。他最终没用上它。在艾森豪威尔将军的指挥下，盟军海军在强大空军的支援下，于今天早上开始在法国北部海岸登陆盟军部队。几天后，一张如今已成为标志性的照片在报纸上刊登。艾克被那些美国伞兵簇拥着，他身体前倾，目光锐利如鹰。
He was lauded as a hero, the general who launched the Great Crusade. He was the epitome of American decisiveness, confidence, command. Ike's failure note, as it has come to be known, was never used and remains little known. But it revealed something profound about leadership. Behind his public confidence was massive doubt, uncertainty and the heavy burden of a decision. This week on Hidden Brain, we explore the hidden power of doubt, not as weakness or indecision,
他被誉为英雄，那位发起“伟大十字军东征”的将军。他是美国人的果断、自信和指挥能力的缩影。艾克的“失败备忘录”（正如后来人们所称的那样）从未被使用，也鲜为人知。但它揭示了关于领导力的一些深刻道理。在他公开的自信背后，是巨大的怀疑、不确定性和决策的沉重负担。本周在《隐藏的大脑》中，我们探讨怀疑的隐藏力量，它不是软弱或优柔寡断，
but as a tool that helps us make better choices, build stronger relationships, and navigate an uncertain world. When you picture a strong leader, what do you see? Someone confident, decisive, unwilling to back down. We don't think of strong leaders as hesitant, doubtful, or unsure of the right answers. Confidence and determination are admirable traits, but they also have drawbacks.
而是一种帮助我们做出更好选择、建立更牢固关系并驾驭不确定世界的工具。当你想象一位强大的领导者时，你看到了什么？一个自信、果断、不愿退缩的人。我们不会认为强大的领导者是犹豫不决、充满怀疑或对正确答案不确定的。自信和决心是令人钦佩的特质，但它们也有缺点。
Confidence can lead to overconfidence. Decisiveness can make leaders less tolerant of dissent. Determination can blind us to risks. At the University of Virginia's Darden School of Business, Biddon Parmar studies the value of doubt. He goes by Bobby, and he says that by avoiding uncertainty, We miss out on opportunities for growth. Bobby Parmar, welcome to Hidden Brain.
自信可能导致过度自信。果断可能使领导者对异议的容忍度降低。决心可能使我们对风险视而不见。在弗吉尼亚大学达顿商学院，比登·帕尔马研究怀疑的价值。他叫鲍比，他说通过回避不确定性，我们错失了成长的机会。鲍比·帕尔马，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。
Shankar, thanks so much for having me. Bobby, some years ago, you went on a 14-day backpacking trip to Wyoming. I understand that you are someone who is prone to allergies. Was this backpacking trip a good idea? I'm not so sure. I am allergic to everything outdoors. And in 2017, in a fit of rebellion, I think I decided to do this 14-day, day backpacking trip in the Wind River Range in Wyoming. This was a group from a course called
尚卡尔，非常感谢邀请我。鲍比，几年前，你去怀俄明州进行了一次为期14天的背包旅行。据我了解，你是一个容易过敏的人。这次背包旅行是个好主意吗？我不太确定。我对户外的一切都过敏。2017年，出于一种反叛心理，我想我决定去怀俄明州的温德河山脉进行这次为期14天的背包旅行。这是一个来自名为
the National Outdoor Leadership School, or Knowles. And so we were a group of 14 strangers. Some folks were younger aspiring to leadership positions. I wanted to do this in part because it was something I had never done before. I am, as I said, allergic to everything outdoors. And this was a way of pushing myself outside of my comfort zone, literally. And there were people who wanted to spend more times outdoors. There were avid backpackers and people like me who were brand new. Bobby's group varied widely,
“国家户外领导力学校”（Knowles）的课程小组。我们是一群14个陌生人。有些人更年轻，渴望担任领导职务。我之所以想这样做，部分原因是我以前从未做过。正如我所说，我对户外的一切都过敏。这是一种将我推向舒适区之外的方法，字面意义上的。有些人想在户外待更长时间。有狂热的背包客，也有像我这样完全的新手。鲍比的小组差异很大，
not just in backpacking experience, but in fitness levels. Half were pretty solid in terms of hiking and carrying a 50-pound backpack, and others were relatively new, and that first week was a huge transition for half of us. You're up pretty early,
不仅在背包旅行经验方面，在体能水平上也一样。一半人在徒步和背负50磅重的背包方面相当扎实，而其他人则相对较新，第一周对我们一半人来说是一个巨大的转变。你起得很早，
between 5.30 and 6, and you're making breakfast as a camp. Then very quickly, you're deciding the plan for the day. You're working together to say, here's where we are. This is where we're trying to get to by this evening. And then very quickly, we're off hiking. And you're hiking for roughly 45 minutes to an hour. And then you take a 15-minute break. And that cycle continues until you reach base camp. How much hiking were you doing each day? Oh, geez. Each day, I'd say maybe 10 to 15 miles a day. Oh my gosh. So how many hours of hiking was this each day? It's like eight to ten hours a day.
在5点半到6点之间，你在营地做早餐。然后很快，你就要决定当天的计划。你们一起工作，说：“我们现在在这里。这是我们今晚要到达的地方。”然后很快，我们就出发徒步了。你徒步大约45分钟到一个小时，然后休息15分钟。这个循环一直持续到你到达大本营。你们每天徒步多少路程？哦，天哪。每天，我想大概10到15英里。哦，天哪。那么每天徒步多少小时？每天大约八到十个小时。
Good grief. Yeah. I just went on a four-hour hike last weekend and I was just exhausted by the end of this four-hour hike. You were doing eight hours every day? Every day for 14 days. Now, we had some days that were half days and there were like optional hike. So we would go and we would be by a lake and there would be an optional hike to summit a peak, for example. And some people would go and other people would stay. at base camp and do laundry or go fishing. So the second half of the expedition, there was a little bit more choice. But the first half was pretty daunting and grueling. Your feet would be completely calloused each evening. My goal was just to make sure that I didn't get helicoptered out of there.
天哪。是的。我上周末刚去徒步了四个小时，结束时我已经精疲力竭了。你每天都要走八个小时？连续14天，每天如此。我们有些日子是半天，还有一些可选的徒步路线。所以我们会去湖边，比如会有一次可选的登顶徒步。有些人会去，其他人则留在营地洗衣服或钓鱼。所以探险的后半段，选择稍微多了一些。但前半段相当艰巨和折磨人。每天晚上你的脚都会磨出厚茧。我的目标只是确保我不会被直升机送出去。
Halfway through the trip, Bobby and his new friends found themselves having to make a difficult judgment call. So this was a day where we were coming out of a wooded area into a more open grassy area. And if you can picture the scene, it's kind of wide open spaces with mountains surrounding you. We're in a valley. We're surrounded by tall grasses, you know, that are kind of waist height. And you look around and you see different levels of mountains. And so it's unclear when you're looking at the topographical map and looking at the contour lines,
旅程过半时，鲍比和他的新朋友们发现自己必须做出一个艰难的判断。那是一天，我们从树林里出来，进入一片更开阔的草地。如果你能想象那个场景，那是相当开阔的空间，周围环绕着群山。我们在山谷里。我们被齐腰高的长草包围着。你环顾四周，看到不同高度的山脉。所以当你看着地形图并观察等高线时，不清楚
Which exact peaks are we looking at when we try to triangulate between the map and what we see on the horizon? And we had to find this lake where we were going to camp that evening. And we weren't sure if the lake was above us or below us or in which direction we had to go. And as you're looking at the topographical map trying to say, okay, it says that there's a peak here, which peak are we looking at? Which peak is the highest peak? And it's very hard to get a sense of where your bearings are when you're looking at those topographical maps. And we were tired and confused, and I just wanted to get in my sleeping bag and go to bed. So the group has to make a decision.
当我们试图在地图和地平线上看到的景象之间进行三角测量时，我们到底在看哪座山峰？我们必须找到今晚要露营的那个湖。我们不确定湖是在我们上方还是下方，或者我们必须朝哪个方向走。当你看着地形图试图说：“好吧，上面说这里有一座山峰，我们在看哪座山峰？哪座是最高峰？”时，很难确定自己的方位。我们又累又困惑，我只想钻进睡袋睡觉。所以小组必须做出决定。
You're not quite sure what to do. What do you end up doing? So I'm exhausted, and I basically say, look, you know, leaders are supposed to be decisive. I think we should move down the mountain. And people pick up their bags, and they start to follow me. At first I was like, look, I'm excited to get back into my sleeping bag. things are great. But then all of a sudden, the terrain started to look different than what we were expecting. There didn't seem to be any water sources nearby. And so, yeah, we started to
你不太确定该怎么做。你最后做了什么？我精疲力竭，基本上说：“看，领导者应该果断。我认为我们应该下山。”人们拿起包，开始跟着我走。起初我心想：“看，我很高兴能回到睡袋里，一切都很棒。”但突然间，地形开始看起来与我们预期的不同。附近似乎没有任何水源。所以，是的，我们开始
feel a little bit like maybe we are going in the wrong direction. But it was easier to keep moving than it was to admit that I was wrong. So you go two hours, you discover that you are not where you want to be. What does the group do? Thankfully, everyone was pretty understanding. And we're all relatively new to reading maps and orienting in the outdoors, and there was some grumbling, but we look back at the map. We try to orient ourselves again, and we realized that the lake was above us the whole time. It was at a higher elevation, which is counterintuitive, right? You think water flows downhill. The lake should be below us. So we packed up our stuff again after reexamining the map and trudged an extra couple of hours
感觉有点像我们可能走错方向了。但继续走比承认我错了更容易。所以你们走了两个小时，发现自己不在想去的地方。小组怎么做？谢天谢地，每个人都相当理解。我们对读地图和户外定向都相对陌生，虽然有一些抱怨，但我们回头看了看地图。我们再次尝试定位，意识到湖一直都在我们上方。它在更高的海拔，这很反直觉，对吧？你认为水往低处流。湖应该在我们下方。所以我们重新检查地图后再次收拾好东西，又艰难地走了几个小时
back to base camp. We did finally make it, but I know that I felt really bad about leading everyone in the wrong direction. One thing I've noticed when I have lost my way, Bobby, is that if I miss my exit on the highway, for example, and I know that I have to go, you know, to the next exit and turn around and come back, that whole journey is just excruciating for me, because every second as I'm driving the wrong direction, I know I'm going to have to come back and go the other direction, and every step feels like it's painful. That must have been your experience as well. Oh, my head was bowed. as I was walking behind the group the whole time. So I'm wondering as you were heading back,
回到大本营。我们最终确实到达了，但我知道因为带领大家走错方向，我感到非常糟糕。鲍比，我注意到当我迷路时，比如我在高速公路上错过了出口，我知道我必须去下一个出口掉头回来，整个过程对我来说简直是折磨，因为我开车走错方向的每一秒，我都知道我必须回来走另一条路，每一步都感觉很痛苦。那一定也是你的经历。哦，我低着头。当我一直走在队伍后面时。所以我很好奇，当你们往回走时，
retracing your steps, climbing back uphill, up this mountainside, do you have a chance to reflect on how you had gone wrong, Bobby? I think it started the reflection that took several months and several years after to really figure out what was going on in that moment. Why was it that I was so eager to be over the decision and to be moving in the right direction? And I think so much of it was discomfort with the uncertainty, with hearing these dissenting opinions
原路返回，爬回山坡，你有机会反思你是怎么走错的吗，鲍比？我想这开启了反思，花了几个月甚至几年时间才真正弄清楚那一刻发生了什么。为什么我那么渴望结束决策并朝着正确的方向前进？我想很大程度上是因为对不确定性的不适，对听到这些不同意见的排斥，
and wanting so much to be in my sleeping bag in a comfortable spot. In that moment, uncertainty was an obstacle. It wasn't a resource. I mean, I can put myself in your shoes. Everyone around you is hungry or tired. You're being bitten by mosquitoes. You don't know which way you're going.
以及非常想钻进睡袋待在一个舒适的地方。那一刻，不确定性是一个障碍，而不是一种资源。我的意思是，我可以设身处地为你着想。周围每个人都又饿又累。你被蚊子叮咬。你不知道该往哪走。
You're trying to get to the sleeping bag. You don't know whether to go up or down. And just making a decision, any decision, feels better than being indecisive. Yeah, that's right. When we come back, how to know when doubt and uncertainty can be our friends. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam.
你正试图钻进睡袋。你不知道该往上走还是往下走。而做出一个决定，任何决定，都感觉比优柔寡断要好。是的，没错。当我们回来时，如何知道怀疑和不确定性何时能成为我们的朋友。你正在收听《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。
As we go through life, all of us are going to face forks in the road. Those can pop up in our personal lives and at work. They can rear up in emergency situations. People might turn to you and say, what should we do? How should we respond? Which way should we go? And seeing their stress and panic and sensing your own stress and panic,
当我们经历人生时，我们所有人都会面临人生的十字路口。它们可能出现在我们的个人生活和工作中。它们可能在紧急情况下突然出现。人们可能会转向你说：“我们该怎么办？我们该如何应对？我们该走哪条路？”看到他们的压力和恐慌，并感受到你自己的压力和恐慌，
you might be tempted to find a way to quickly soothe the distress. A quick decision can feel reassuring. It can make the fear subside. But at the University of Virginia, Bobby Parmar says there are times when reassurance is not our friend. Bobby, your story of your mistake during the hike
你可能会试图找到一种方法来迅速缓解这种痛苦。一个快速的决定会让人感到安心。它可以让恐惧消退。但在弗吉尼亚大学，鲍比·帕尔马说，有时安慰并不是我们的朋友。鲍比，你徒步旅行中犯错的故事
illustrates a common quirk of the mind, which is that we hate to sit with uncertainty. talk about why this might be the case? You know, when we're in school, we learn that being smart means getting the right answer. People like to be what I call right answer getters. Certainty makes us feel really great, right? It feels like we have agency and we have control over our lives. But there are also some serious downsides to certainty.
说明了大脑的一个常见怪癖，那就是我们讨厌处于不确定性之中。谈谈为什么会这样？你知道，在学校里，我们学到聪明意味着得到正确答案。人们喜欢成为我所说的“正确答案获取者”。确定性让我们感觉非常好，对吧？感觉我们有能动性，能掌控自己的生活。但确定性也有一些严重的缺点。
It can make us really overconfident. It can get us to ignore competing perspectives. We can underestimate risks. I'm also reflecting on the fact. that sometimes when we are in a state of uncertainty, the uncertainty itself feels aversive. It feels like, I don't know which way to go. I feel confused. I feel, I feel distressed. And there's a part of us that actually just wants to suppress that distress. Yes, for sure. Many of us do experience uncertainty or doubt as this aversive feeling. And neuroscience suggests
它会让我们变得非常过度自信。它会让我们忽视相互竞争的观点。我们会低估风险。我也在反思这样一个事实：有时当我们处于不确定状态时，不确定性本身会让人感到厌恶。感觉就像：“我不知道该走哪条路。我感到困惑。我感到痛苦。”我们内心的一部分实际上只是想压制这种痛苦。是的，当然。我们许多人确实将不确定性或怀疑视为一种厌恶的感觉。神经科学表明
that that's because the parts of the brain that are related to understanding uncertainty or out, are related to the parts of the brain where we experience kind of aversive feelings. They're very close together. So I'm curious about what exactly does go on in the brain when we are faced with these difficult choices like you were with the map that day. You say that there is a trio of interconnected systems in the brain that regulate our behavior in different types of situations, and these systems work together to influence how we experience uncertainty. Tell me about what you call the pursue system, a part of the brain that involves
这是因为大脑中与理解不确定性或怀疑相关的部分，与我们体验某种厌恶感觉的大脑部分是相关的。它们非常接近。所以我很好奇，当我们面临像你那天看地图时那样的艰难选择时，大脑中到底发生了什么。你说大脑中有一组相互关联的系统在调节我们在不同情况下的行为，这些系统共同影响我们如何体验不确定性。告诉我你所说的“追求系统”，这是大脑中涉及
the prefrontal cortex and the ventral striest. Yeah, this is what others have called the mesolimbic pathway or our reward system. We anticipate something in the future or something further away from us being enjoyable, desirable, desirable, pleasurable, and it works primarily through a neuromodulator called dopamine. Dopamine makes anticipation feel good. And so we exert energy to get up and go after that valuable future state or further state of affairs. So on the side of the mountain, exhausted after seven days of the moment, exhausted after seven days of of hiking, you're dreaming about being in your sleeping bag. You're dreaming about sitting by the campfire and not having to hike another 10 hours. That is my happy place. So this contrasts
前额叶皮层和腹侧纹状体的一部分。是的，这就是其他人所说的中脑边缘通路或我们的奖励系统。我们预见到未来或离我们较远的事物是令人愉快的、可取的、令人向往的，它主要通过一种名为多巴胺的神经调节剂起作用。多巴胺让期待感觉良好。因此，我们付出精力去追求那个有价值的未来状态或更远的事物。所以在山坡上，经过七天的徒步旅行后精疲力竭，你梦想着钻进睡袋。你梦想着坐在篝火旁，不必再徒步10个小时。那是我的快乐之地。这与
with a part of the brain that involves the amygdala, the hypothalamus, the adrenal cortex, and the autonomic nervous system. And you call this the protect system? Yeah, because its goal is to protect us from both physical and social threats. When we look out in the environment and see something that could be potentially threatening, we have a response to either fight, fly, or freeze. And this is a system that regulates that kind of behavior. How do the pursue and the protect systems interact when it comes to decision-making, Bobby?
大脑中涉及杏仁核、下丘脑、肾上腺皮质和自主神经系统的一部分形成了对比。你称之为“保护系统”？是的，因为它的目标是保护我们免受身体和社会威胁。当我们观察环境并看到可能具有潜在威胁的事物时，我们会做出战斗、逃跑或冻结的反应。这就是调节这种行为的系统。鲍比，在决策方面，追求系统和保护系统是如何相互作用的？
So both of these systems work really well when there are clear signals in our environment to say this is something that we should approach or avoid. So in other words, chocolate cookie, my system says, great, approach. Grizzly bear, my system says, avoid, run, very straightforward. Absolutely. Except when there are signals that we don't know how to interpret because they're not
所以，当环境中有明确信号表明这是我们应该接近或回避的事物时，这两个系统都能很好地工作。换句话说，巧克力饼干，我的系统说：“太棒了，接近。”灰熊，我的系统说：“回避，跑。”非常直接。绝对是。除非有我们不知道如何解读的信号，因为它们不是
clear signals. So sometimes there's a very same stimulus that you want to approach and avoid simultaneously. Should I break the rules to help my friend? I want to help my friend. That's something I want to approach. But I don't want to break the rules. That's something I want to avoid. Sometimes we find ourselves in situations where there are two things we want to approach. We're not quite sure which one. Or two things we want to avoid. And we're not sure which one I should avoid first. And so when there are these multiple conflicting interpretations of what we should do, the brain doesn't have a single clear signal, then the third system gets to work. And this is what I call our pause and piece together system. This system involves multiple brain
明确的信号。所以有时同一个刺激是你既想接近又想回避的。我应该为了帮助朋友而打破规则吗？我想帮助我的朋友。那是我想要接近的事物。但我不想打破规则。那是我想要回避的事物。有时我们发现自己处于有两种我们想接近的事物的情况。我们不太确定哪一个。或者有两种我们想回避的事物，我们不确定应该先回避哪一个。因此，当对我们应该做什么有多种相互冲突的解释时，大脑没有一个单一明确的信号，那么第三个系统就开始工作了。这就是我所说的“暂停并拼凑系统”。这个系统涉及多个大脑
regions, but it recruits our attention and our working memory in order to get us to look around and say which of these conflicting interpretations should I pay attention to. This is a system that creates our experience of doubt. surf back in the mountainside that day and explain how these three brain systems were working in your brain as you were confronting the choice you had to make, Bobby. So as we're sitting there huddled around this map, debating and discussing which way we should hike and why, my pause and piece together system is noticing that there are these different interpretations of what we should do. Should we go up the mountain? Should we go down the mountain?
区域，但它会调动我们的注意力和工作记忆，让我们环顾四周并说：“这些相互冲突的解释中，我应该关注哪一个？”这是一个创造我们怀疑体验的系统。回到那天山坡上的情景，解释一下当你面临必须做出的选择时，这三个大脑系统是如何在你的大脑中工作的，鲍比。所以当我们挤在地图周围，争论和讨论我们应该走哪条路以及为什么时，我的“暂停并拼凑系统”注意到对我们应该做什么有不同的解释。我们应该上山吗？我们应该下山吗？
But I'm also tired. I'm also hungry. I'm itchy from all the bug bite. And this doubt that I'm seeing in front of me is also something that feels aversive. My protect system is telling me, Bobby, we should get out of here. We need to find our way back to that sleeping bag, back to that campfire. And in those moments, what happens is pause and piece together. System activity diminishes. Protect system activity increases. And I say, let's go.
但我又累又饿。我被虫子咬得发痒。我面前看到的这种怀疑也让我感到厌恶。我的保护系统在告诉我：“鲍比，我们应该离开这里。我们需要找到回到那个睡袋、回到那个篝火旁的路。”在那些时刻，发生的事情是“暂停并拼凑系统”的活动减少了，“保护系统”的活动增加了。于是我说：“走吧。”
We're moving down the hill. We're going to get to safety. In one study, neuroscientists modified the functioning of a part of the brain to stimulate this third network in the brain. What happened when they did this, Bobby? So we should mention that when neuroscientists do this, they do this with the utmost care and consent and supervision. But they can use technologies to temporarily inhibit or promote the functioning of these different brain areas. And when they temporarily inhibit the functioning of the pause and piece together, other system, what you see is that people become much more impulsive and much more reactive to
我们下山。我们要去安全的地方。在一项研究中，神经科学家修改了大脑一部分的功能来刺激大脑中的这个第三网络。当他们这样做时发生了什么，鲍比？所以我们应该提到，当神经科学家这样做时，他们是在极其谨慎、征得同意和监督的情况下进行的。但他们可以使用技术来暂时抑制或促进这些不同大脑区域的功能。当他们暂时抑制“暂停并拼凑系统”的功能时，你看到的是人们变得更加冲动，对
whatever stimuli they're given. So if they're given a gambling task, they're much more likely to gamble and not be very careful about how they're gambling because they're not able to regulate their impulses. If they're given a task where they have to cheat, they're much more likely to cheat because they can't regulate their impulse to say, no, maybe we shouldn't be cheating. So how does this system in the brain almost like a referee system, you know, it's deciding, you know, who gets the point? Is it the player on the left or the player on the right? What happens to the system when we're stressed, when we're exhausted? Do these things affect how these systems work in
他们被给予的任何刺激都更加反应强烈。所以如果给他们一个赌博任务，他们更有可能去赌博，而且在赌博时不太谨慎，因为他们无法调节自己的冲动。如果给他们一个必须作弊的任务，他们更有可能作弊，因为他们无法调节自己说“不，也许我们不应该作弊”的冲动。那么，当我们在压力下、精疲力竭时，大脑中的这个系统（就像一个裁判系统，你知道，它决定谁得分？是左边的球员还是右边的球员？）会发生什么？这些事情会影响这些系统在
the brain? Absolutely. One of the things that we know is that acute stress upregulates our dopamine receptors. And so what that means is it makes us much more reactive when we're seeing different things in our environment that might promise relief from the stress that we're feeling. The other important piece about this is stress is something that's negative. But the same thing can happen when we're very excited about something that's positive. Like when, you know, we're going off to that cookie or going after a conversation with a good friend, things in our environment become blurred in order to propel our action towards the thing that we're trying to approach or avoid. You say that one of the things that happens when this inhibitory system, this referee system in the brain is affected,
大脑中的工作方式吗？绝对会。我们知道的一件事是，急性压力会上调我们的多巴胺受体。这意味着当我们看到环境中可能预示着缓解我们所感受到的压力的不同事物时，我们会变得更加反应强烈。关于这一点的另一个重要部分是，压力是负面的。但当我们对积极的事物感到非常兴奋时，也会发生同样的事情。比如，当我们去拿那个饼干或与好朋友交谈时，环境中的事物会变得模糊，以推动我们采取行动去接近或回避我们试图追求或回避的事物。你说当大脑中的这个抑制系统（这个裁判系统）受到影响时，发生的事情之一是，
is that we start to trust our intuition much more. Can you talk about what happens when we do this, Bobby? So intuitions are incredibly important to our decision making. There's a really famous set of studies done in the early 2000s on something called moral dumbfounding. And these experimenters had this really clever design, and they brought participants in, and they asked them about these scenarios that were morally repulsive, but harmless. So they would ask them things like, is it okay for siblings to have consensual sex if they use contraception and protection? Is it okay for someone to have sex with chicken and then eat it, for example?
我们开始更加信任我们的直觉。你能谈谈当我们这样做时会发生什么吗，鲍比？所以直觉对我们的决策非常重要。2000年代初进行了一系列非常著名的关于“道德哑口无言”的研究。这些实验者有一个非常巧妙的设计，他们带入参与者，询问他们关于这些在道德上令人反感但无害的情景。所以他们会问他们诸如：“如果兄弟姐妹使用避孕措施和保护措施，进行双方同意的性行为可以吗？”“比如，有人与鸡发生性关系然后吃掉它，可以吗？”
And as we can imagine, these participants in these studies were repulsed by all of these scenarios. And they would say, no, of course it's not okay. This is terrible. Nobody should do this. And then the experimenters would ask them, well, why? And then they would say things, well, you know, they could get a disease if they had consensual sex without, but they used protection. Or the person didn't get sick.
正如我们可以想象的那样，这些研究中的参与者对所有这些情景都感到反感。他们会说：“不，当然不可以。这太可怕了。没人应该这样做。”然后实验者会问他们：“好吧，为什么？”然后他们会说：“嗯，你知道，如果他们进行双方同意的性行为而不使用保护措施，他们可能会得病。”“但他们使用了保护措施。”“或者那个人没有生病。”
They would give all these counter examples. And finally, the participants would say, well, I don't know why it's wrong, but it's just wrong. What does this tell us about how these brain systems are working, Bobby? What the authors of these studies argue is that people have an intuitive reaction first, that this is wrong, and then they come back and justify that intuition with reasoning. So I know that this is wrong, and now I'm going to come up with three different reasons why it's wrong. But what the authors argue is that, people aren't thinking first and then deciding they're having an intuition and then rationalizing
他们会给出所有这些反例。最后，参与者会说：“嗯，我不知道为什么它是错的，但它就是错的。”鲍比，这告诉我们这些大脑系统是如何工作的？这些研究的作者认为，人们首先有一种直觉反应，即这是错的，然后他们回来用推理来证明这种直觉。所以我知道这是错的，现在我要想出三个不同的理由来证明它是错的。但作者认为，人们不是先思考然后决定，他们是先有直觉，然后
afterwards. So in other words, it seems to us as if we've thought through a decision before we come to it, but what you're saying is we've actually come to the decision and we're actually explaining the decision to ourselves afterwards. Exactly. Intuition works really well as a guide for our decisions when we're in familiar circumstances. So when we've seen a situation repeatedly, we have an intuition that we've got to make this choice or that choice, our intuition is a really good guide because we have experience to back
事后合理化。所以换句话说，在我们做出决定之前，我们似乎已经深思熟虑了，但你所说的是，我们实际上已经做出了决定，并且实际上是在事后向自己解释这个决定。完全正确。当我们处于熟悉的环境中时，直觉作为我们决策的指南非常有效。所以当我们多次看到某种情况时，我们有一种必须做出这个选择或那个选择的直觉，我们的直觉是一个非常好的指南，因为我们有经验来支持
that intuition up. There are times, though, where our intuition can lead us astray, particularly when we're in novel circumstances, when we're encountering things that we haven't encountered before, or when they're competing interpretations, intuition isn't always a good guide for our decision-making. And so we've got to be careful about when we rely on our intuition and when we try to educate our intuition. I remember talking with the great psychologist Danny Kahneman many years ago, and he was telling me about how, you know, in some of his earliest studies,
那种直觉。然而，有时我们的直觉会把我们引入歧途，特别是在新颖的情况下，当我们遇到以前从未遇到过的事情时，或者当有相互竞争的解释时，直觉并不总是我们决策的好指南。所以我们必须小心什么时候依赖我们的直觉，什么时候尝试教育我们的直觉。我记得多年前与伟大的心理学家丹尼·卡尼曼交谈，他告诉我，在他的一些早期研究中，
he looked at the effect of, you know, selecting people just based on intuition. So, you know, you're trying to pick the right person for a job, and you say, well, I think this person's going to do pretty well. And it turns out that's a terrible way to pick people, because, in fact, our intuitions are really awful. But he found that if you actually went through all of the details of people's biographies and resumes and learned everything there was about them. And then you close the book,
他研究了仅凭直觉选择人的效果。所以，你试图为一个工作挑选合适的人，你说：“嗯，我认为这个人会做得很好。”结果发现这是一种挑选人的糟糕方法，因为事实上，我们的直觉真的很糟糕。但他发现，如果你实际上仔细阅读了人们的传记和简历，了解了关于他们的一切。然后你合上书，
and then you asked yourself, which is the best candidate for the job? Now your intuition becomes informed intuition. You're actually basing it on a base of knowledge, and in fact it becomes quite accurate. That's exactly right. And so one of the things I work with my students is not to ignore our intuition,
然后问自己：“谁是这份工作的最佳候选人？”现在你的直觉变成了“知情直觉”。你实际上是基于知识基础，事实上它变得相当准确。完全正确。所以我和学生们一起工作的一件事就是不要忽视我们的直觉，
but to take that intuition as a starting point. One big challenge when it comes to judging our intuitions is that when we go out and test our intuitions, we often have a propensity to find evidence that matches our intuition. Can you talk about the role of confirmation bias in how we deal with doubt and the role that it plays in intuition?
而是把那种直觉作为一个起点。在判断我们的直觉时，一个巨大的挑战是，当我们去测试我们的直觉时，我们往往有一种倾向，去寻找与我们直觉相符的证据。你能谈谈确认偏误在我们处理怀疑时所起的作用，以及它在直觉中扮演的角色吗？
Remember that when we make decisions primarily by relying on our pursue system or our protect system, the goals of both of those systems is to catalyze action, to catalyze approach or avoidance. And in the process of doing that, in the process of catalyzing action, those systems actually take uncertainties or ambiguities
记住，当我们主要通过依赖我们的追求系统或保护系统来做出决定时，这两个系统的目标都是催化行动，催化接近或回避。在这个过程中，在催化行动的过程中，这些系统实际上会把我们在世界上可能看到的不确定性或模糊性
we might see in the world and make them certain. And so information that we might have gotten us to think differently about our choices, we reinterpret as actually being in line with our choices. And there's a lot of research that shows, for example, that after having made a choice, if you give people an opportunity, for example, to look at data, they're going to look at data that's much more consistent with the choice that they made. They can look at anything they want. They can look at information about a defendant that they decided was innocent and not guilty,
变得确定。因此，我们可能得到的本可以让我们对选择有不同思考的信息，被我们重新解释为实际上与我们的选择一致。有很多研究表明，例如，在做出选择后，如果你给人们一个机会，例如查看数据，他们会查看与他们所做选择更一致的数据。他们可以看任何他们想看的东西。他们可以看关于一个他们认定是无辜且无罪的被告的信息，
and they're much more likely to read stories that are consistent with the decision that they made. And whether that decision is about a court case, a product they bought, their health choices, after having made a decision, we tend to stop learning and focus on things that make us feel like we made the right choice. And again, I think this might have happened on your mountainside hike.
他们更有可能阅读与他们所做决定一致的故事。无论这个决定是关于法庭案件、他们购买的产品还是他们的健康选择，在做出决定后，我们往往会停止学习，专注于那些让我们觉得做出了正确选择的事情。再说一次，我认为这可能发生在你山坡上的徒步旅行中。
I mean, you're basically, as you start going, perhaps two hours into the mistake, you recognize that it's a mistake. But for the first 15 minutes, you're probably finding all kinds of evidence that basically tells you that you made the right decision. Exactly. In that moment, I wanted us to be moving in the right direction. And it's so much easier to see all of the information coming at you as confirming your initial choice to move down the hill.
我的意思是，基本上，当你开始走的时候，也许在犯错两个小时后，你意识到这是一个错误。但在最初的15分钟里，你可能找到了各种各样的证据，基本上告诉你做出了正确的决定。完全正确。在那一刻，我希望我们朝着正确的方向前进。而且，将所有向你涌来的信息视为证实你最初下山的选择要容易得多。
It's so easy to convince yourself that, yeah, see, that peak over there, that's the one on the mountain. We're going in the right direction. We also talked about this briefly in the context of your mountainside expedition, which is that you effectively became the leader of this little group. And you had decided to take this group down the mountainside because that's where you thought the lake was. And at some point, as you were walking in the wrong direction, you started to have a sneaky feeling that you may have been going in the wrong direction, but you found it difficult in some ways to say, hang on a second, let's reevaluate. Can you talk about the role that blame avoidance plays in our decision-making?
说服自己太容易了：“是的，看，那边那座山峰，就是地图上的那座。我们走对了方向。”我们也曾在你山坡探险的背景下简短地谈过这一点，那就是你实际上成为了这个小组的领导者。你决定带这个小组下山，因为你认为湖在那里。在某个时刻，当你走错方向时，你开始有一种鬼鬼祟祟的感觉，觉得你可能走错了方向，但你发现以某种方式说“等一下，让我们重新评估”很困难。你能谈谈责备回避在我们的决策中扮演的角色吗？
Blame is a form of social punishment. And when we experience blame or we even anticipate that blame is coming, it revs up our protect system activity. We anticipate there's going to be some negative social interaction happening in our environment, and it makes it much more difficult to learn, to experience doubt as something that can open up the possibility of learning, it makes doubt feel like a liability. Something is wrong with me.
责备是一种社会惩罚。当我们经历责备，甚至预见到责备即将到来时，它会加速我们保护系统的活动。我们预见到环境中会发生一些负面的社会互动，这使得学习变得更加困难，使得将怀疑体验为一种可以开启学习可能性的东西变得更加困难，它让怀疑感觉像是一种负担。我出了什么问题。
And so when we anticipate blame, it shuts learning down. And there are lots of examples of this. A recent example from the headlines are things like the crisis at Boeing. You know, engineers tried to raise issues about the quality of the engineering on the 737 max. And they experienced senior leaders at Boeing as saying, no, actually, we've got to make sure that we're delivering on time and under budget, and raising issues about quality or safety was seen as something that was inefficient. People felt like they would be blamed if they were raising those issues.
因此，当我们预见到责备时，它会关闭学习。这有很多例子。头条新闻中最近的一个例子是波音公司的危机。你知道，工程师试图提出关于737 Max工程质量的问题。他们经历过波音公司的高级领导者说：“不，实际上，我们必须确保我们按时交付且预算内完成。”而提出关于质量或安全的问题被视为效率低下。人们觉得如果他们提出这些问题，他们会受到责备。
And so they stopped raising those issues. When we feel threatened, when we anticipate blame, it's so easy for doubt to lead to confirmation of our beliefs, not conversation. It's also striking to me, Bobby, that when we look out on our social landscape, we often have a tendency to want to follow people who are extremely confident. The political leaders who seem like they're the most effective leaders seem to know exactly where to lead us. The business leaders who we feel are good business leaders seem to know exactly what they want to do. Talk a little bit about this.
所以他们停止提出这些问题。当我们感到受到威胁，当我们预见到责备时，怀疑太容易导致对我们信念的确认，而不是对话。鲍比，令我震惊的是，当我们审视我们的社会景观时，我们往往有一种倾向，想要追随那些极其自信的人。看起来最有效的政治领导人似乎知道到底该把我们带向何方。我们认为好的商业领袖似乎知道他们到底想做什么。谈谈这一点。
The social norms we have all basically valorize the role of decisiveness. Yeah. You know, when we all internalize this message that being smart means getting the right answer, Then when we look around and we see people who confidently project having the right answer, it's easy to defer to them and say, well, I might not be feeling as certain about this. But this person over there, they seem to know. And it alleviates some of the discomfort we might feel when we experienced doubt. And it allows us to follow that person and say, well, maybe they have the right answer because I know I don't.
我们拥有的社会规范基本上都推崇果断的作用。是的。你知道，当我们都内化了“聪明意味着得到正确答案”这一信息时，当我们环顾四周，看到那些自信地表现出拥有正确答案的人时，很容易顺从他们并说：“嗯，我可能对这件事感觉没那么确定。但那个人，他们似乎知道。”它减轻了我们在经历怀疑时可能感受到的不适。它让我们能够跟随那个人并说：“嗯，也许他们有正确答案，因为我知道我没有。”
You know, I'm thinking about some work looking at what happens in crisis situations like terrorist attacks. there was this very interesting set of studies that was done at the World Trade Center. This was not during the 9-11 attacks, but during a bombing that took place some years earlier. And it found that largely what people did was shaped by what the people around them were doing. So in other words, if there was someone in your workplace that decided to stay put, you ended up staying put. If someone decided to make a hasty exit, you and everyone else jumped up. And in some ways, I don't think we like to think of ourselves as being cheap, but what the research suggests is that we are heavily influenced by the people around us.
你知道，我正在思考一些研究，观察在恐怖袭击等危机情况下会发生什么。在世界贸易中心进行了一系列非常有趣的研究。这不是在9-11袭击期间，而是在几年前发生的一次爆炸期间。研究发现，人们所做的事情在很大程度上是由周围人的行为所塑造的。换句话说，如果你的工作场所里有人决定留在原地，你最终也会留在原地。如果有人决定匆忙撤离，你和其他所有人都会跳起来。在某种程度上，我不认为我们喜欢认为自己是盲从的，但研究表明我们深受周围人的影响。
And as a social species, that's a huge cue of how we should be behaving. If I see people running, I better run. If I see people carrying on with like nothing happen, then maybe I should be doing the same. One of my favorite studies that illustrates a similar effect takes place in Manhattan. And the researchers had this very clever design where they just wanted to measure how they could influence the behavior of people who were passing by on the street. And they put one research assistant on the street corner. and the person was just looking up at the skyline,
作为一种社会性物种，这是我们应该如何表现的一个巨大线索。如果我看到人们在跑，我最好也跑。如果我看到人们像什么都没发生一样继续生活，那么也许我也应该这样做。我最喜欢的一项说明类似效果的研究发生在曼哈顿。研究人员有一个非常巧妙的设计，他们只是想衡量他们如何影响街上路人的行为。他们在街角放了一名研究助理，
and they were just measuring how many people would stop and also look up. And when they put one person there, almost nobody stops, right? It's New York. There's always people doing crazy things. Just keep walking in your own direction. But when they put three research assistants on the corner looking up, virtually every person who crossed the street also stopped and looked up to say, what are they looking at? They must be looking at something.
那个人只是抬头看着天际线，他们只是在测量有多少人会停下来也抬头看。当他们放一个人在那里时，几乎没人停下来，对吧？这是纽约。总有人在做疯狂的事情。继续朝你自己的方向走。但当他们在街角放了三名研究助理抬头看时，几乎每个过马路的人也都停下来抬头看，想说：“他们在看什么？他们一定在看什么东西。”
I've seen a variation of this that is actually even funnier, where you have people walking into an elevator, and you have a group of five research assistants who are basically standing in the elevator, and then a person comes in, and this is the person who is the unsuspecting study participant, and then all five people turn and face in one direction on the elevator. They turn to the left,
我见过这种现象的一个变体，实际上更有趣，你让人们走进电梯，你有一组五名研究助理基本上站在电梯里，然后一个人进来，这就是那个毫无戒心的研究参与者，然后所有五个人都转身面向电梯的一个方向。他们向左转，
and then this poor sixth person looks around and sees five people facing to the left, and slowly, sheepishly turns around and looks to the left. And after seven seconds, everyone turns and looks to the back of the elevator, and this person turns again, and you have these videos of this poor person basically slowly turning around in the elevator based on what these other five people are doing,
然后这个可怜的第六个人环顾四周，看到五个人面向左边，慢慢地、羞怯地转过身，看向左边。七秒钟后，每个人都转身看向电梯后面，这个人又转了一次，你就有这些视频，这个可怜的人基本上根据其他五个人在做什么，在电梯里慢慢地转来转去。
and it really paints a picture of exactly what you're talking about. Yeah, my heart goes out to those participants in those studies, but it's such a human thing. It's such a human thing when we walk into any environment, we don't know what to do, we default to what others around us are doing. When we come back, Bobby gets the chance to redeem himself on another hiking trip.
这确实生动地描绘了你所谈论的内容。是的，我非常同情那些研究中的参与者，但这是一种非常人性化的表现。当我们走进任何环境时，如果我们不知道该做什么，我们就会默认跟随周围人的做法，这太人性化了。当我们回来时，鲍比有机会在另一次徒步旅行中挽回自己的形象。
plus strategies for leaning into doubt to make better decisions in your own life. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Have you had moments in your life when you felt impelled to make a quick decision? Did it turn out well? Did it turn out disastrously? If you have a story you'd be willing to share from your own life with the Hidden Brain audience, please find a very quiet room or a walk-in clothes closet and record a voice. voice memo on your phone. Email it to us at ideas at hiddenbrain.org. Use the subject line,
以及在生活中利用怀疑来做出更好决策的策略。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是香卡·维丹塔姆。这是《隐藏的大脑》。我是香卡·维丹塔姆。你的生活中是否有过那种迫使你做出快速决定的时刻？结果好吗？还是灾难性的？如果你愿意与《隐藏的大脑》的听众分享你生活中的故事，请找一个非常安静的房间或步入式衣橱，用手机录下一条语音备忘录。发送电子邮件至 ideas@hiddenbrain.org。请使用主题行：
doubt. We generally think of doubt as a bad thing. Our minds are wired for certainty. Not knowing the answer to something feels uncomfortable, even threatening. Bobby Parmar is the author of radical doubt, turning uncertainty into surefire success. He says doubt doesn't have to be the enemy. In fact, it can be our friend. Bobby, we talked earlier about your trip to Wyoming and how you got yourself and the rest of your crew lost looking for a campsite. A year after that happened, you went to Patagonia.
怀疑。我们通常认为怀疑是一件坏事。我们的大脑天生追求确定性。不知道某件事的答案会让人感到不舒服，甚至感到威胁。鲍比·帕尔马是《激进的怀疑：将不确定性转化为确定的成功》一书的作者。他说怀疑不一定是敌人。事实上，它可能是我们的朋友。鲍比，我们之前谈到了你去怀俄明州的旅行，以及你是如何因为寻找露营地而让自己和团队迷路的。那件事发生一年后，你去了巴塔哥尼亚。
I've never visited. Describe the landscape to me and how you came to be on this trip. Patagonia is a place where in every direction you look, the vistas are incredibly beautiful. I've never been to a place where every direction you look is just breathtaking. This is a year later, and I'm aware. with 12 of my MBA students, also now taking outdoor leadership course in the wilderness in
我从未去过那里。请向我描述一下那里的风景，以及你是如何踏上这次旅行的。巴塔哥尼亚是一个无论你向哪个方向看，景色都美得令人难以置信的地方。我从未去过一个无论向哪个方向看都令人叹为观止的地方。这是一年后，我带着12名MBA学生，当时也在参加户外领导力课程，在荒野中……
Patagonia. And so we had just camped at the summit of a very snowy peak, and our goal was to find our new base camp near a river. So we had to come off the mountain, find this river, and then follow the rivers away to our new campsite. So we start to hike down, and very quickly we come off of the kind of rocky peak of the mountain into densely wooded forest. So it's very hard to see where we're going. And, you know, I thought to myself at the time, look, we're just descending a mountain. How hard can it be? You're just going down.
巴塔哥尼亚。我们刚在一个积雪覆盖的山峰顶上露营，我们的目标是在河边找到新的大本营。所以我们必须下山，找到这条河，然后沿着河道走到我们的新营地。我们开始徒步下山，很快就从岩石嶙峋的山峰进入了茂密的森林。所以很难看清我们要去哪里。而且，你知道，当时我心想，看，我们只是在下山。这能有多难？你只需要往下走就行了。
But very quickly, we started to hit ravine after ravine or thick brush after thick brush. And we found ourselves pretty trapped. We didn't know how to descend a mountain as simple as it sounds. And in that moment, I felt very similar to how I felt when I was in Wyoming. Despite being on a completely different hemisphere, it was like deja I'm wondering whether you used what happened to you the previous year in Wyoming to help you in the situation, Bobby. What did you do? So this time, I didn't let, you know, my desire to make it to base camp get the better of me. And so together with my students, instead of barreling forward or giving up too quickly, we decided to actually hike back up the mountain so we could get a better view of where we were.
但很快，我们开始遇到一个又一个沟壑，或者一片又一片茂密的灌木丛。我们发现自己被困住了。我们不知道如何下山，听起来很简单。那一刻，我的感觉和在怀俄明州时非常相似。尽管身处完全不同的半球，但这就像似曾相识。鲍比，我想知道你是否利用了前一年在怀俄明州的经历来帮助你应对这种情况？你是怎么做的？所以这一次，我没有让我想到达大本营的渴望冲昏头脑。因此，我和学生们没有盲目向前冲或过早放弃，而是决定实际上爬回山上，这样我们就能更好地看清我们所在的位置。
And so we made it back up the mountain and started to trace out different paths, looking at. If we walk down this way, then it looks like there's a ravine that way. We shouldn't go that way. What about going this way? And we tried out multiple different options until we found one that we felt was safest. This time, instead of feeling like hiking back up the mountain is a waste of time or inefficient, it was like an investment in learning. It was a way of saying, you know what, yes, it's not moving in a straight line to our goal,
于是我们爬回了山上，开始规划不同的路径，观察着。如果我们走这边，那边看起来有个沟壑。我们不应该走那边。走这边怎么样？我们尝试了多种不同的选择，直到找到一个我们认为最安全的。这一次，与其觉得爬回山上是浪费时间或效率低下，不如说这是一种学习投资。这是一种说法，你知道吗，是的，这不是直线走向我们的目标，
but it's allowing us to zoom out and see where we are so we do actually reach our goal. You know, this reminds me in some ways of something that I think is ascribed to Albert Einstein. He once said, if I had an hour to solve a complex problem, I would spend 55 minutes thinking about the problem and five minutes thinking about the solution. In some ways, that mirrors exactly what you're talking about here. Yeah, I love that quote as well. But the tricky thing is that when you try to get people to think about the problem and not the solution, that can be very painful. people don't like doing that. We jump to solutions because that part feels so much more fun than really wrestling with a problem. One of the things I'm trying to change about my own language when I talk about doubt is that I've learned that doubt isn't something that we sit with.
但这让我们能够拉远视角，看清我们身处何处，从而真正实现我们的目标。你知道，这在某种程度上让我想起了阿尔伯特·爱因斯坦的一句话。他曾说，如果我有一个小时来解决一个复杂的问题，我会花55分钟思考问题，花5分钟思考解决方案。在某种程度上，这完全反映了你在这里所说的。是的，我也很喜欢那句名言。但棘手的是，当你试图让人们思考问题而不是解决方案时，这可能会非常痛苦。人们不喜欢那样做。我们直接跳向解决方案，因为那部分比真正纠结于问题本身要有趣得多。我在谈论怀疑时试图改变自己语言的一点是，我了解到怀疑不是我们应该“坐视”的东西。
Sitting with doubt feels like this very passive thing. No one wants to sit with something that's uncomfortable. What I've noticed when I examine people who are really good at making decisions under conditions of uncertainty is they're actively, engaging the doubt. So they're naming what it is. They're generating hypotheses about how to address it. They're looking for strengths and weaknesses in those hypotheses. They're playing with different solutions, all of which are very active and engaged. One of the ways that you and other suggest that we can use doubt as this kind of hypothesis building exercise is demonstrated in a study that looked at how military officers come up with decisions. Tell me about the study and what it found. This is such an interesting study.
“坐视”怀疑感觉像是一件非常被动的事情。没有人愿意坐视让自己不舒服的事情。当我观察那些在不确定条件下非常擅长做决策的人时，我注意到他们是在积极地应对怀疑。他们会明确怀疑是什么。他们会提出解决怀疑的假设。他们会寻找这些假设的优缺点。他们会尝试不同的解决方案，所有这些都是非常积极和主动的。你和其他人建议我们可以将怀疑作为一种假设构建练习的方法之一，在一项研究中得到了证明，该研究观察了军事指挥官如何做出决策。告诉我这项研究及其发现。这是一项非常有趣的研究。
So what they did is they compiled all of this complex information about a battlefield scenario, the weather, the direction and location of different armies and where they were situated, their logistics and weapons. And they gave all of this complex information to two types of participants. Some were novices. They were captains. And others were much more experienced. They were generals.
他们所做的是汇编了关于战场情景的所有复杂信息，天气、不同军队的方向和位置以及他们的驻扎地、后勤和武器。他们将所有这些复杂信息提供给两类参与者。一类是新手。他们是上尉。另一类是经验丰富的人。他们是将军。
And what they asked both of these groups to do is to say, why don't you read through all of this complex information? It's conflicting and uncertain. And write down some questions that you want to ask. And then write down a strategy. What do you think you should do in this situation? And so after they captured all that information, they had an independent panel of judges,
他们要求这两组人做的是：为什么不通读所有这些复杂的信息呢？这些信息是相互矛盾且不确定的。写下一些你想问的问题。然后写下一个策略。你认为在这种情况下你应该做什么？在他们收集了所有这些信息后，他们请了一个独立的评审小组，
look at the questions and the strategies of both of these groups, one novice group, the captains, and the more experienced group, the generals. And they noticed some really interesting patterns. The patterns that they noticed were novices were, much more likely to treat their intuition as if it was their decision. I think this is what we should do in the battle, and here's some data that suggests that my strategy is the right strategy.
查看这两组人（新手组，即上尉；经验丰富的组，即将军）的问题和策略。他们注意到了一些非常有趣的模式。他们注意到的模式是，新手更有可能将他们的直觉视为他们的决定。我认为这就是我们在战斗中应该做的，这里有一些数据表明我的策略是正确的策略。
With the exact same information, experts saw that data as much more complicated and nuanced. They decided to treat their intuition, not as a decision, but as a hypothesis. They were asking questions about key uncertainties. They built strategies that were flexible and had mitigation strategies so how could we fall back if something goes wrong? The level of their thinking was just much more careful and nuanced than the novices, even with the same information. Is there evidence that this is true across different industries, Bobby? This is a finding that's been replicated in lots of different domains.
面对完全相同的信息，专家们认为数据要复杂和微妙得多。他们决定将他们的直觉视为一个假设，而不是一个决定。他们会询问关于关键不确定性的问题。他们构建的策略是灵活的，并且有缓解策略，所以如果出了问题，我们该如何退后？他们的思维水平比新手要谨慎和微妙得多，即使面对相同的信息。鲍比，是否有证据表明这在不同行业中都是真实的？这是一个在许多不同领域都被重复验证的发现。
People who are experienced dealing with doubt are just much more sensitive to their surroundings. So when we look at expert entrepreneurs, entrepreneurs who've started several businesses, when they talk about a business concept, they're just much more able to see, here are all the ways in which this business concept could impact different stakeholders. They're able to assess what are the unintended outcomes of this business concept.
处理怀疑经验丰富的人对周围环境更加敏感。所以当我们观察专家企业家时，那些创办过几家企业的企业家，当他们谈论一个商业概念时，他们更能看出这个商业概念可能对不同利益相关者产生的所有影响。他们能够评估这个商业概念的意外后果是什么。
And they can also think about here like the second or third order consequences of this business concept. They're just much more careful thinkers. When we look at nurses, when nurses are making an uncertain diagnosis, they collect twice as much data when compared to novice nurses
他们也能思考这个商业概念的二阶或三阶后果。他们是更谨慎的思考者。当我们观察护士时，当护士做出不确定的诊断时，与新手护士相比，她们会收集两倍的数据
about the exact same patient. expert lawyers are much better at scanning the courtroom and adapting their arguments in real time based on what they're seeing in the jury. Expert writers spend a lot more time revising their drafts than novice writers. All of this suggests that people who are experienced when it comes to dealing with uncertainty and doubt are more sensitive to their surrounding and they're investing in learning. They're not investing in trying to get to a right answer quickly. I mean, it's almost a paradox, Bobby. the people who are the most experienced are the most hesitant to quickly come to a conclusion. Yeah, that's what I think is so interesting, is many of us who are not at the top of our industry or running organizations, who don't see ourselves as experts, look at experts and say, wow, they have the right answer and look how decisive they are.
关于同一个病人。专家律师更擅长审视法庭，并根据他们在陪审团中看到的情况实时调整他们的论点。专家作家花在修改草稿上的时间比新手作家多得多。所有这些都表明，在处理不确定性和怀疑方面经验丰富的人对周围环境更敏感，并且他们是在投资于学习。他们不是在投资于试图快速得到正确答案。我的意思是，这几乎是一个悖论，鲍比。最富有经验的人，反而是最犹豫不决、不愿匆忙得出结论的人。是的，我认为这非常有趣，我们许多人并不是行业顶尖人物或管理组织的人，我们不认为自己是专家，我们看着专家说，哇，他们有正确的答案，看看他们多么果断。
And then when you spend time with people who have significant experience and expertise, they're actually investing time in becoming what I call better answer makers, not right answer getters. You say that some of this work points to another important strategy we can use to make better decisions, and it's called anomalizing. What is anomalizing, Bobby? Anomalizing is basically looking for very early signals that something is departing from our expectations. Going back all the way to when I was in Wyoming, looking at the ridge line and saying, wait, this is really different than what we would expect if the lake was nearby would be a form of anomalizing. as a parent saying, oh, my kid isn't eating their lunch. I wonder if something is going wrong, is anomalizing. So it's looking for early, weak signals that maybe our expectations aren't turning out the way that we anticipate.
然后当你与那些拥有丰富经验和专业知识的人在一起时，他们实际上是在投入时间成为我所说的“更好的答案制定者”，而不是“正确答案获取者”。你说这些工作中的一些指向了我们可以用来做出更好决策的另一个重要策略，它被称为“异常化”。什么是异常化，鲍比？异常化基本上是寻找某些事物偏离我们预期的早期信号。回到我在怀俄明州的时候，看着山脊线说，等等，这与如果湖泊在附近我们所预期的真的非常不同，这就是一种异常化。作为父母说，哦，我的孩子没吃午饭。我想知道是不是出了什么问题，这就是异常化。所以它是在寻找早期的、微弱的信号，表明我们的预期可能并没有像我们预想的那样发展。
In other words, what you're trying to do is you're trying to say, how can I be wrong? Exactly. And a great way of practicing that in teams, in organizations, is something that's called a premortem. So you take an idea, a strategy, we're going to launch a new product, or we're going to change this internal process. And before doing anything, we say, okay, let's imagine that we launch this product or we change this process. And three weeks later, it failed. It died. What is the most likely cause of death?
换句话说，你试图做的是问自己：我怎么可能是错的？完全正确。在团队和组织中练习这一点的一个好方法是所谓的“预演”（premortem）。所以你拿出一个想法、一个策略，我们要推出一个新产品，或者我们要改变这个内部流程。在做任何事情之前，我们说，好吧，让我们想象一下我们推出了这个产品或者改变了这个流程。三周后，它失败了。它死了。最可能的死因是什么？
What is the most likely reason that we might fail? And by anticipating that most likely reason of failure, we can do something about it ahead of time. In some ways, this builds on a very interesting idea, which is that many of us in some ways are able to look back at a decision. and understand how that decision happened. We have what's called hindsight bias. So in some ways, this is taking advantage of our propensity to look back at an event that's already happened and try and use that hindsight bias in some ways prospectively
我们可能失败的最可能原因是什么？通过预见那个最可能的失败原因，我们可以提前采取措施。在某种程度上，这建立在一个非常有趣的想法之上，即我们许多人在某种程度上能够回顾一个决定，并理解那个决定是如何发生的。我们有所谓的“后见之明偏差”。所以从某种程度上说，这是利用我们回顾已经发生的事件的倾向，并试图以某种方式前瞻性地利用这种后见之明偏差，
to say, let's assume the bad thing has happened. Let's try and explain why this bad thing had happened. And now you're using this fact-finding mission to basically say, how can we fix the problem before it happens? That's right. How can we fix the problem? Or if we run into the problem, how can we be adaptable and flexible to work our way around it?
去说，让我们假设坏事已经发生了。让我们试着解释为什么会发生这件坏事。现在你正在利用这个事实调查任务来基本上说，我们如何在问题发生之前解决它？没错。我们如何解决这个问题？或者如果我们遇到了这个问题，我们如何能够适应和灵活地绕过它？
You give the very interesting example of Airbnb. It's obviously a multi-billion dollar company with millions of properties around the world, clearly a huge success. But in 2007, you say the company was on the verge of bankruptcy. What was happening, Bobby? Airbnb is a brilliant idea. You know, when you look at it on paper or on slide decks, the idea of having people rent out or lease their properties
你举了一个非常有趣的Airbnb的例子。它显然是一家价值数十亿美元的公司，在全球拥有数百万处房产，显然是一个巨大的成功。但在2007年，你说这家公司处于破产边缘。发生了什么，鲍比？Airbnb是一个绝妙的主意。你知道，当你在纸上或幻灯片上看到它时，让人们出租或租赁他们的房产的想法
makes so much sense. But in the actual implementation of the idea, the founders learned that they had some more work to do. So early on, they started to say, we built this beautiful system. People can lease their properties. The back-end financial system works really well. You can get credit card transactions to work.
非常有道理。但在该想法的实际实施中，创始人了解到他们还有更多工作要做。所以早期，他们开始说，我们建立了这个漂亮的系统。人们可以租赁他们的房产。后端财务系统运行得非常好。你可以让信用卡交易成功。
But no one was actually renting properties, and they couldn't figure out why. So they got really curious, and they said, why don't we spend some time with some of our customers? and they watched customers actually navigate the Airbnb website. And one of the first things they learned is at the time when people were posting their properties in Manhattan, they were posting very grainy cell phone photos. So you couldn't see the quality of the place that you were renting.
但实际上没有人租房，他们搞不清楚原因。所以他们变得非常好奇，他们说，为什么我们不花点时间和我们的一些客户在一起呢？他们观察了客户如何实际浏览Airbnb网站。他们学到的第一件事是，当时人们在曼哈顿发布房产时，他们发布的是非常模糊的手机照片。所以你无法看出你所租房子的质量。
And people would say, well, why would I spend $250 or $300 a night for this place that looks really grainy? I can't quite tell what it is. I could stay in a really nice hotel for the same price. And so that led them to this other hypothesis, which is, why don't we have someone take professional photos of some of these properties. And they found very quickly that properties with professional photos rented very quickly. And what's important about this story is that many times when we're making decisions, we focus on the what. What's the business that we build in order to get
人们会说，好吧，我为什么要花每晚250或300美元租这个看起来很模糊的地方？我看不出它是什么。我可以花同样的钱住一家非常好的酒店。所以这引导他们得出了另一个假设，即为什么我们不找人给其中一些房产拍专业照片呢。他们很快发现，有专业照片的房产租得非常快。这个故事的重要之处在于，很多时候当我们做决定时，我们关注的是“什么”。我们为了让人们能够出租他们拥有的房产而建立的业务是什么？
people to be able to rent out property that they have? We spend less attention to the how. And when we focus on the what, it's really easy to have a big abstract vision that has lots of assumptions baked into it. And there's lots of things that we don't know. And we can convince ourselves that we're right. But when we focus on the how, we have to become much more specific. And it focuses us to imagine which much more discipline and much more detail how we're going to get from point A to point B. It also strikes me, Bobby, that so much of what you're talking about is so closely connected with the scientific method. If you think about why science itself has been effective, so radically effective over the last
我们对“如何”关注较少。当我们关注“什么”时，很容易产生一个宏大的抽象愿景，其中包含了许多假设。而且有很多我们不知道的事情。我们可以说服自己我们是对的。但当我们关注“如何”时，我们必须变得更加具体。它迫使我们以更严谨、更详细的方式想象我们将如何从A点到达B点。鲍比，这也让我想到，你所谈论的很多内容与科学方法密切相关。如果你思考为什么科学本身是有效的，在过去两个世纪里如此激进地有效，
two centuries, so much of it has been about the embrace of doubt, the embrace of uncertainty, the testing of ideas, as opposed to just going with your gut. Yeah, I think that's exactly right. Observation, generation of hypothesis, testing those hypotheses and then leading to new observations is critical to learning. What I think is really important to underscore when we think about the importance of the scientific method is that many times we think about learning as a predominantly cognitive endeavor. But when we embrace doubt, we have to understand that learning is just as much a social and emotional endeavor.
很大程度上是因为拥抱怀疑，拥抱不确定性，测试想法，而不是仅仅凭直觉行事。是的，我认为这完全正确。观察、提出假设、测试这些假设，然后引出新的观察，这对学习至关重要。我认为当我们思考科学方法的重要性时，非常重要的一点是，很多时候我们认为学习主要是一种认知努力。但当我们拥抱怀疑时，我们必须明白，学习同样是一种社会和情感努力。
And when we take doubt seriously, we take very seriously the way that people experience the world, both emotionally and socially, to preserve learning. So I'm getting a couple of things from, this. One is that I think when we sit with the problem and we sit with the doubts that we might have about a problem or sit with the uncertainties involved in the problem, we start to see first how complex the problem is, that in fact it's more complex than we might have allowed previously. But second, we also discover that there are actually more solutions than we initially thought about. Yeah, that's right. When we cannot engage doubt, there are all kinds of phases in the
当我们认真对待怀疑时，我们非常认真地对待人们在情感和社会层面上体验世界的方式，以保持学习。所以我从中学到了几点。一是，我认为当我们坐下来面对问题，坐下来面对我们可能对问题产生的怀疑，或者坐下来面对问题中涉及的不确定性时，我们开始首先看到问题有多复杂，事实上它比我们之前可能认为的要复杂得多。但第二，我们也发现实际上有比我们最初想到的更多的解决方案。是的，没错。当我们不能参与怀疑时，决策过程中的各种阶段，从界定问题到产生替代方案，再到测试这些替代方案，再到实施，我们可能会无意中缩短或匆忙完成。当我们能够参与怀疑时，当我们将其视为学习的信号时，我们就不会匆忙完成这些阶段。我们在创造新颖选择、更有效地实施方面可以更有效。我认为关于怀疑要记住的重要一点是，它就像我们在健身房锻炼时在第八次或第九次重复时感受到的灼烧感。如果我们在那一刻放弃，我们就放弃了变得更强壮的机会。我认为怀疑就是那种灼烧感。它是一个信号，表明我即将变得更有能力。
decision-making process, from framing a problem to generate. alternatives to testing those alternatives to implementation that we can inadvertently shortchange or rush through. And when we're able to engage doubt, when we see it as a signal for learning, we don't rush through those stages. We can be much more effective in creating novel options, in implementing more effectively. I think one of the important things to remember about doubt is that it's like the burn that we feel when we're working out at the gym on rep eight or rep nine. If we were to give up in that moment, we'd be foregoing actually getting stronger. And I think about doubt as that burn. It's a signal that I'm about to become much more capable.
在那一刻，我即将变得更强壮或更明智。所以当我们经历怀疑时，记住它是一个成长的信号，而不是我们不够聪明的信号，这非常重要。鲍比，你如何看待今天那些听起来极其自信的政治领导人？我想知道当你观看新闻，看到人们以极大的自信宣布如果实施或不实施某项政策，两年后会发生什么事情时，你的脑海里在想什么？在那些时刻，我认为的一件事是，你知道，这感觉就像你在向你的听众提供一种成瘾物质，在那一刻，你的听众就像，
I'm about to become stronger or wiser in that moment. And so when we experienced doubt, remembering that it's a signal for growth rather than a signal that we're not smart is really important. What do you make of political leaders who sound extremely confident today, Bobby? I'm wondering when you watch the news and you see people make pronouncements with great confidence about things that will happen two years from now if a particular policy is implemented or not implemented, what goes through your head? One of the things that I think in those moments is that, you know, it just feels like you're offering an addictive substance to your audience, that in that moment, your audience is like,
啊，有一些确定性了。我知道这会发生。在那一刻，你吸引了很多人，没有人能做出那些承诺，但在那一刻听到它们感觉太好了。所以这就像提供一种人们很难拒绝的成瘾物质，即使他们可能知道这不符合他们的长期最佳利益。换句话说，即使他们过去在某种程度上被误导或失望，因为你之前的承诺未能实现，你提供的确定性在某种程度上感觉像是一种药物，基本上说它限制了我感到的不确定性，这让我感觉更好。
ah, there's some certainty. I know this will happen. And you're pulling people a lot of in that moment, no one can make those promises, but it feels so good to hear them in the moment. So it's like offering some addictive substance that people have a hard time saying no to, even if they might know that it's not in their best long-term interest. In other words, even if they have been in some ways misled or disappointed in the past because your previous promises have failed to materialize, the certainty that you're offering in some ways feels like a drug that basically says it limits the uncertainty I'm feeling and that makes me feel better.
在信息时代，我们必须非常小心的一件事是这种对“感觉正确”的成瘾风险。我们所有的社交媒体环境都可以被完全制造出来，以帮助我们对现有的信念集感觉良好。我们许多人开始将那种“不知道”的感觉与非常不舒服联系起来，因为我们太习惯于“感觉正确”了，这可能是一件令人上瘾的事情。鲍比·帕尔马是《激进的怀疑：将不确定性转化为确定的成功》一书的作者。鲍比·帕尔马，非常感谢你今天参加《隐藏的大脑》。香卡，这真是我的荣幸。
One of the things we have to really be careful of in the information age is this risk of the addiction to feeling right. All of our social media environments can be completely manufactured to help us feel good about our existing set of beliefs. And many of us come to associate that feeling of not knowing as very uncomfortable because we're so used to feeling right, it can be an addictive thing. Bidin Pammar is the author of Radical, doubt, turning uncertainty into surefire success. Bobby Pirmar, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Shankar, it was such a pleasure.
如果你有一个关于处理怀疑的个人故事，愿意与《隐藏的大脑》听众分享，或者对本集有任何问题或评论，请找一个非常安静的房间，用手机录下一条语音备忘录。两三分钟就足够了。将文件通过电子邮件发送给我们：Feedback@hiddenbrain.org。请使用主题行：怀疑。那个电子邮件地址再次是 feedback@hiddenbrain.org。今天的节目是我们为期一个月的“U2.0”系列的总结。
If you have a personal story about dealing with doubt that you would be willing to share with the Hidden Brain audience or a question or comment about this episode, please find a very quiet room and record a voice memo on your phone. Two or three minutes is plenty. Email the file to us at Feedback at Hiddenbrain.org. Use the subject line, doubt. That email address again is feedback at hiddenbrain.org. Today's episode is the conclusion to our month-long U2.0 series.
在过去的几周里，我们谈到了勇气、耐心和螺旋式上升的心理学。我们还研究了当你陷入困境时该怎么办。如果你错过了这些节目中的任何一集，你可以在这个播客订阅源或 hiddenbrain.org 上找到它们。当我们回来时，当有人给我们反馈而我们反应糟糕时，到底发生了什么？研究员艾米丽·福克回到节目中，回答听众关于防御性的问题。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是香卡·维丹塔姆。这是《隐藏的大脑》。我是香卡·维丹塔姆。你知道你不应该说什么。这真的不是什么大不了的事。
Over the past few weeks, we've talked about courage, patience, and the psychology of spiraling. We've also looked at what to do when you get stuck in a rut. If you missed any of these episodes, you can find them in this podcast feed or at hiddenbrain.org. When we come back, what's really happening when someone gives us feedback and we react badly? Researcher Emily Falk returns to the show to answer listeners questions about defensiveness. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. You know you shouldn't say anything. It's really not such a big deal.
你告诉自己要保持和平。毕竟，你的伴侣把洗碗机装错了真的有那么重要吗？但它确实很重要，你脑海中的小声音低语道。你不记得上周打碎的那个酒杯了吗？在我们所有人的生活中，周围的人都会做一些让我们抓狂的事情。如果不是你的伴侣装洗碗机的方式，那就是你爸爸倒车进入停车位的方式，或者是你同事在会议中打断你的烦人倾向。
You tell yourself to keep the peace. After all, does it really matter that your partner loads the dishwasher all wrong? But it does matter, whispers the little voice in your head. Don't you remember the wine glass that broke last week? In all of our lives, the people around us do things that drive us up the wall. If it's not the way your partner loads the dishwasher, it's the way your dad backs into a parking space or your colleague's annoying tendency to interrupt you in a meeting.
有时我们让这些事情过去。在其他时候，我们感到不得不说出来，无论是为了我们自己，还是为了对方的利益。但从这种反馈中获得好的结果并不容易。很有可能，对方会觉得我们在挑剔他们或唠叨。他们会变得防御。那么我们能做些什么来让给予和接受反馈的过程不那么令人紧张呢？这就是艾米丽·福克发挥作用的地方。
Sometimes we let these things slide. At other times, we feel compelled to speak up, either for our own sake or for the other person's benefit. But getting a good result from this sort of feedback is not easy. Chances are, the other person will feel that we're picking on them or nagging. They'll become defensive. So what can we do to make the process of giving and receiving feedback a little less fraught? That's where Emily Falk comes in.
她是宾夕法尼亚大学的心理学家，也是我们之前一集名为《这不是我的错》的《隐藏的大脑》的嘉宾。今天，艾米丽回到节目中，在我们受欢迎的环节“你的问题已解答”的最新一期中回应你们的评论。艾米丽·福克，欢迎回到《隐藏的大脑》。谢谢你邀请我回来。艾米丽，你在之前的谈话中指出，我们对反馈产生防御性反应的一个原因是，我们的大脑将“我是谁”与“什么是好的”联系在一起。你是什么意思？嗯，在我们的大脑中，我们有一个系统叫做价值系统，它
She's a psychologist at the University of Pennsylvania and our guest on a previous episode of Hidden Brain titled It's Not My Fault. Today, Emily returns to the show to address your comments in our latest installment of our popular segment, your questions answered. Emily Falk, welcome back to Hidden Brain. Thanks for having me back. Emily, you pointed out in our earlier conversation that one reason we respond defensively to feedback is because our minds associate what is me with what is good. What do you mean by that? Well, in our brains, we have a system called the value system that.
帮助我们评估事物是好是坏，是否可能对我们有回报。我们还有一个自我相关系统，帮助我们决定事物是“我”还是“非我”。有趣的是，这两个系统确实是交织在一起的。所以，区分我是否认为某种特质（如“凌乱”或“聪明”）适用于我的大脑模式，也可以区分我是否在看一张我认为是积极的图片，比如生日派对，还是消极的，比如一堆垃圾或血腥场景。在我们的日常生活中，这种情况出现在许多不同的地方，从我们持有的物理事物开始。所以现在，我一直在思考很多。我一直在帮助我妈妈处理清理东西
helps us evaluate whether things are good or bad, likely to be rewarding for us. And we also have a self-relevance system that helps us decide whether things are me or not me. And interestingly, those two systems are really intertwined with one another. So the same kinds of brain patterns that differentiate between whether I think that a particular trait like messy or intelligent applies to me can also differentiate whether I'm looking at an image that I think is positive. like a birthday party or negative, like a pile of trash or a gory scene. And in our day-to-day lives, this comes up in so many different places, starting with the physical things that we hold on to. So right now, I've been thinking a lot. I've been helping my mom navigate clearing out stuff
在她家里。我们安排了搬家公司下周来把她家剩下的东西搬走。为了准备这一点，我最近花了很多时间翻看我童年的很多东西。所以其中一些东西非常重要，是我会珍视的，比如我爸爸为我做的凳子，那个小时候上面有字母E的小木凳，我百分之百会留着。但也有一些东西只是杂物，比如我在高中和大学里记了数百页笔记的所有教科书和笔记本。比如我在高中学到的关于中美洲革命的事情，有书比我16岁时那种片面的理解更好地描述了这些情况。
in her house. And we have movers scheduled to come and take the rest of the stuff out of her house next week. And in preparation for that, I have spent so much time recently going through a lot of my childhood things. So some of those things are really important and things that I'm going to hold dear, like the stool that my dad made for me, the little wooden stool that has an e on it when I was a kid, that 100% I'm keeping. But then there's also stuff that would just be clutter, like all of the textbooks and notebooks that have hundreds of pages of notes that I took. in high school and college. Like the things that I learned about, you know, revolutions in Central America in high school, there are books that do a much better job of describing those situations than my, you know, partial understanding as a 16-year-old.
然而，翻看那些笔记本，看到我的笔迹，想到我当时是谁，感觉很难放手并把它们扔掉。我认为这源于这样一个想法：我认为是“我”的东西，在某种程度上也具有与看别人的笔记本不同的内在价值。我能看出那可能不是我需要保留的东西。因此，自我与价值的交织有时确实非常有益，因为它帮助我们保持积极的自我感。但它也可能让我们陷入麻烦，因为我们紧紧抓住过去所做的事情或我们认为是自己一部分的东西。换句话说，当你的伴侣告诉你你装洗碗机的方式不对时，
And yet, going through those notebooks and seeing my handwriting and thinking about who I was at the time, it feels so hard to let go of those things and throw them out. And I think that comes from this idea that things that I think of as me are also then kind of inherently valuable in a different way than, you know, looking at somebody else's notebook. I can see that that's probably not something that I need to keep. And so that intertwining of self and value is sometimes really beneficial because it helps us maintain a positive sense of self. but it can also get us in trouble because we hold really tightly to the things that we've done in the past or to things that we think of as being part of us. So in other words, when your partner tells you that you're loading the dishwasher wrong,
你听到的不仅仅是可能有另一种装洗碗机的方法。你在某种程度上也听到了对这种自我感的攻击。是的，我认为我们倾向于将自我与价值混为一谈的方式确实会以那种方式让我们陷入麻烦。有人在给我们建议、指导或输入，这些本来可能对我们有益。而我们没有听到潜在的有价值的真理核心，却听到了一些暗示关于我们是谁以及我们可能有什么能力的事情，或者在评估比那里可能处于危险之中更大的事情。我们在《隐藏的大脑》中经常谈论的一个事实是，我们通过我们的意图来评估自己，
you're not just hearing that there might be a different way to load the dishwasher. You're also hearing in some ways an attack on this sense of self. Yeah, I think that the ways that we tend to conflate self-in-value can get us in trouble in exactly that way. that somebody is giving us advice or coaching or input that might otherwise be beneficial for us. And instead of hearing the potentially valuable kernel of truth, we hear something that is suggesting all kinds of things about who we are and maybe what we're capable of or evaluating something bigger than might be at stake there. One of the things we talk about with some regularity on Hidden Brain is the fact that we assess ourselves by our intentions.
但其他人不一定知道我们打算做什么。他们只能看到我们的行为。你认为我们对自己的思想和意图有洞察力，这就是为什么当有人批评我们的行为时我们有时会感到防御的原因吗？这是一个非常有趣的框架方式。我认为这种我们可以理解为什么我们做某事是这样一种想法，对于我们作为给予批评的人来说是一个非常有价值的洞察。所以当我们思考我们将如何构建要求时，
but other people don't necessarily know what we intended to do. They can only see our actions. Do you think the fact that we have insight into our own thoughts and intentions is why we feel defensive sometimes when someone critiques our actions? That's a really interesting way of framing it. I think that this idea that we can understand why we did something is such a valuable insight for when we're the person giving the critique. So when we think about how we're going to frame the requirements,
让我们的伴侣以不同的方式装洗碗机，他们脑子里可能有很多我们无法接触到的事情。所以你提出的是，在另一面，我们也认为我们为什么做我们所做的事情是非常明显的。有很多原因在这一天已经发生的事情或我们经历过的其他过去经验方面是显著的。那是一个充斥着各种误解的空间。对。我想到一位教练基本上在建议一名运动员，并要求运动员做一些能提高运动员表现的事情。而运动员在想，但你不知道我有多精疲力竭，我有多累，我脑子里在处理多少不同的事情。你只是要求我做这额外的一件事，而你没有注意所有会让我在遵循你的建议时感到困难的背景。哦，我很高兴你提到了教练的例子，因为我认为教练的例子是一种我们双方都同意参与条款的情况。对。
to our partner to load the dishwasher differently, there might be all kinds of things that are on their minds that we don't have access to. And so what you're proposing is that on the other side of it, we also think it's really obvious why we did what we did. There are so many reasons that are salient in terms of what happened already in our day or other past experiences we've had. That's a space that's rife for miscommunication of all kinds. Right. I'm thinking about a coach who's basically advising an athlete and is asking the athlete to do something that would improve the athlete's performance. And the athlete is thinking, but you don't know how exhausted I am, how tired I am, how many different things I'm juggling in my head. You're just asking me to do this one additional thing and you're not paying attention to all the context that's going to make it difficult for me to follow your advice. Oh, I love that you bring up the coach example because I think the coach example is a situation where we've both agreed on the terms of engagement. Right.
我们已经同意，如果你是教练，我是运动员，大概我已经报名接受你的建议了。我们也已经同意，你正在尝试做一些符合我利益的事情，那就是让我在这项运动或活动中变得更好。所以如果我付钱让你做我的游泳教练，例如，你给我一些建议，它实际上真的降低了机会。
We've agreed that if you're the coach and I'm the athlete, presumably I've signed up to get your advice. And we've also agreed that you are trying to do something that's in my interest, which is make me better at whatever the sport or activity is. So if I'm paying you to be my swim coach, for example, and you give me some advice, it actually really reduces the chance. that I'm going to say, well, you know, why is Shankar telling me to do it that way? Because the terms of engagement are much clearer than the dishwasher situation where there are so many other variables at play where, you know, I'm not your dishwasher coach. And so we haven't actually agreed that I give you input about those kinds of household chores. Right. And in fact, in some situations, we both think that we are the coach and the other person
我会说，好吧，你知道，为什么香卡要告诉我那样做？因为参与条款比洗碗机的情况要清晰得多，在洗碗机的情况中，有太多其他变量在起作用，你知道，我不是你的洗碗机教练。所以我们实际上并没有同意我给你关于那些家务事的输入。对。事实上，在某些情况下，我们都认为我们是教练，而另一个人
is our trainee. Of course. So we heard from several people who called in to share the difficulties they've had in dealing with friends or family members who get defensive about feedback. Here's a message we received from listener, Katie. How can someone stay calm and grounded when dealing with a loved one who becomes highly defensive or even aggressive, especially when the reaction feels just proportionate or personal? Basically, how do you honor their feelings without absorbing or engaging in the negativity? I really like the way that Katie presents this dilemma, Emily.
是我们的学员。当然。所以我们听到了几个人打来电话分享他们在处理对反馈感到防御的朋友或家人时遇到的困难。这是我们收到的听众凯蒂的消息。在处理变得高度防御甚至具有攻击性的亲人时，一个人如何保持冷静和脚踏实地，特别是当反应感觉不成比例或个人化时？基本上，你如何在不吸收或参与消极情绪的情况下尊重他们的感受？艾米丽，我真的很喜欢凯蒂提出这个困境的方式。
When we're having a tough conversation, it can be important to acknowledge how the other person is feeling. But when we feel that someone's response is disproportionate to the situation at hand, it can be really difficult to acknowledge all of what they are feeling instead of saying, just listen to me. Yeah. First of all, just as a little bit of background, there's amazing neuroscience research about the ways that the assumptions that we bring to an interaction or to even just hearing a story change the way that our brains respond to it. So in research where people were given different backstories before hearing a narrative about a man who,
当我们进行艰难的谈话时，承认对方的感受可能很重要。但当我们觉得某人的反应与手头的情况不成比例时，要承认他们所有的感受而不是说“听我说”可能会非常困难。是的。首先，作为一个小背景，有惊人的神经科学研究表明，我们带入互动甚至仅仅是听一个故事的假设会改变我们大脑对它的反应方式。所以，在研究中，人们在听到一个关于一个男人的叙述之前被给予了不同的背景故事，
it's ambiguous whether he's having an affair and half of the participants are given a backstory that makes it really clear that he is and half of the participants are given a backstory that makes it really clear that he isn't. And then what we see is that the brain responses of the people who share the first backstory are really similar to one another, but they really diverge from the people who are given the alternative facts, the alternative backstory. And so our assumptions work like that too. When we're coming into an interaction and I think that our conversation is about the dishwasher and you think that our conversation is about, you know, whether we take time to do things that are important to the other person, then like if I'm
关于他是否在搞婚外情是不明确的，一半的参与者被给予了一个让他非常清楚地在搞婚外情的背景故事，而另一半参与者被给予了一个让他非常清楚地没有搞婚外情的背景故事。然后我们看到的是，分享第一个背景故事的人的大脑反应彼此非常相似，但它们与被给予替代事实、替代背景故事的人的大脑反应确实分歧很大。所以我们的假设也是这样工作的。当我们进入一个互动时，我认为我们的谈话是关于洗碗机的，而你认为我们的谈话是关于，你知道，我们是否花时间做对对方重要的事情，那么如果我
I'm just thinking this is about when we do the dishes. It shouldn't be a big deal. But if for you, there's lots of other things that are wrapped up in it, then, you know, it's unlikely that we're going to make the same meaning of that conversation. And so, you know, in Katie's comment, I'm certainly not proposing that people engage in situations where somebody is being disrespectful or, you know, where safety's at stake. but in a situation where it seems like somebody has a bigger emotional response than you were expecting, I think being curious and thinking about asking for a little bit more information about what's going on for them to be really helpful.
我只是认为这是关于我们什么时候洗碗。这不应该是什么大不了的事。但如果对你来说，里面包裹着很多其他事情，那么，你知道，我们不太可能对那次谈话做出相同的意义。所以，你知道，在凯蒂的评论中，我当然不是建议人们参与到某人表现得不尊重或，你知道，安全受到威胁的情况中。但在某人似乎有比你预期的更大的情绪反应的情况下，我认为保持好奇并考虑要求多一点关于他们正在经历什么的信息是非常有帮助的。
Now, sometimes when we offer feedback to another person and they react defensively, we are tempted to say, why are you acting defensively? And that turns out not to be a very effective strategy to get somebody to act less defensively. When you think about the response that you're making and saying, why are you reacting defensively, that implies a fault in some way, right? Because defensiveness is not typically something that we think of as a positive way of interacting. This reminds me a little bit, actually, of something that happened to me with my kids last week where I have two kids who are twins and they came home three days in a row from school off the bus. basically in tears. They were so angry about what was happening in their ride home from school. And in particular, what was happening was that there's a seven-year-old who's on the bus with them who was
有时候，当我们向他人提供反馈而对方表现出防御性时，我们很想问：“你为什么要表现得这么有防御性？”事实证明，这并不是让对方减少防御性的有效策略。当你思考自己的回应并说“你为什么要表现得这么有防御性”时，这在某种程度上暗示了对方有过错，对吧？因为防御性通常不被我们视为一种积极的互动方式。这让我想起上周我和孩子们之间发生的一件事，我有两个孩子是双胞胎，他们连续三天放学坐校车回家时基本上都在哭。他们对放学回家路上发生的事情感到非常愤怒。具体来说，是因为车上有一个七岁的孩子，他
really effective at dividing them, at sort of doing all kinds of things to provoke, to provoke big emotional reactions from the kids. And my kid Emmett came in and he was just like, I can't handle this. This is like so awful. like he's being terrible. And I said, you know, I think it might be helpful to have a conversation. Like, how would you feel about giving the other child's mama call? And we could just talk about it. And Emmett's initial reaction was that he would really like to do that. But what he would like to do is tell the mom all of the reasons why her child was not behaving in a way that worked for Emmett.
非常擅长挑拨离间，做各种各样的事情来激怒他们，引发他们强烈的情绪反应。我的孩子埃米特（Emmett）回来后说：“我受不了了。这太糟糕了。他表现得太恶劣了。”我说：“你知道吗，我觉得进行一次谈话可能会有帮助。比如，你觉得给那个孩子的妈妈打个电话怎么样？我们可以谈谈这件事。”埃米特最初的反应是他非常愿意这样做。但他想做的是告诉那位妈妈，她的孩子表现得不符合埃米特期望的所有原因。
And to get her to, you know, punish that kid in some way. And what I said to him was, well, we can't really come into the conversation, assuming that your friend is at fault here. Because if we come in that way, what kind of reaction do you think you're going to get? And eventually, after he had had a minute to do a different activity, calm down, we called the other family. And we had a really great conversation. And I think the crux of that, the insight that the kids were able to generate with some coaching was, that this younger kid really wanted Emmett's attention. He really wanted to be able to engage and to play.
并让她以某种方式惩罚那个孩子。我对他说：“我们不能在假设你的朋友有过错的情况下进行谈话。因为如果我们那样做，你觉得会得到什么样的反应？”最终，在他花了一分钟做其他活动冷静下来之后，我们给另一个家庭打了电话。我们进行了一次非常棒的谈话。我认为谈话的核心，也就是孩子们在引导下能够得出的洞察是：那个年幼的孩子其实非常渴望得到埃米特的关注。他真的很想参与进来一起玩。
And when Emmett was doing things like reading instead of interacting, that that was painful or frustrating. And so he was willing to do all kinds of things in order to get Emmett's attention. And so the setup of this phone call, I think, would have gone very differently if Emmett had come in initially saying, here are all the reasons why I think what you're doing is wrong,
当埃米特做阅读而不是互动之类的事情时，他会感到痛苦或沮丧。所以他愿意做各种各样的事情来吸引埃米特的注意。因此，我认为如果埃米特最初进来时就说“我认为你所做的一切都是错的，原因如下”，那么这次通话的基调将会完全不同，
then we get a defensive reaction and I think Emmett would say that then it's his fault for not engaging in the conversation, right? And so I say that to say that I think the way that we set up the context of the conversation matters a lot. And so having some initial relationship
那样我们就会得到防御性的反应，我想埃米特会说那是他的错，因为他没有参与谈话，对吧？所以我说这些是想表达，我认为我们设定谈话背景的方式非常重要。因此，建立一些初步的关系，
where we talk to each other about things that are hard and where we have the assumption that the other person has good intentions is so important. So if we just start with the moment of the confrontation, we've already sort of lost the battle, right?
让我们能够就困难的事情进行交流，并假设对方怀有善意，这一点非常重要。所以如果我们直接从对抗的那一刻开始，我们就已经输掉了这场战斗，对吧？
We want to have this mental and emotional preparation going in that makes it possible for us to do all these other things that are beneficial. You know, this reminds me, Emily, about this idea that psychologists have talked about for a long time, the fundamental attribution error. We see the mistakes that other people make as reflecting their inner dispositions, but we often see our mistakes as the product of our situations. In other words, we see our failure. and mistakes in context, but often fail to extend the same grace to others.
我们在进入谈话时需要进行心理和情感上的准备，这使我们能够做所有其他有益的事情。你知道，这让我想起了心理学家长期以来讨论的一个概念，即基本归因错误。我们将他人的错误视为其内在性格的反映，但我们往往将自己的错误视为环境的产物。换句话说，我们看待自己的失败和错误时会考虑背景，但往往无法对他人给予同样的宽容。
A listener named Michael offered this theory about why humans might be bad at taking criticism. I wonder how much, based on Dr. Fox's comments, these trends are the result of evolution, making us able to deflect responsibility for our faults, or put it another way. When I succeed, it's because of me. I attribute my success to me. And when I fail, I attribute it to my environment or something. an external threat. And I don't know if Dr. Falk would ever comment on that, but thank you very much. What do you think, Emily? I think Michael is exactly right here. As you said, the fundamental
一位名叫迈克尔的听众提出了一个关于为什么人类可能不擅长接受批评的理论。我想知道，基于福克斯博士的评论，这些趋势在多大程度上是进化的结果，使我们能够推卸对自己错误的责任，或者换句话说：当我成功时，是因为我自己的原因。我将成功归功于自己。而当我失败时，我将其归因于环境或某种外部威胁。我不知道福克斯博士是否会对此发表评论，但非常感谢。你觉得呢，艾米丽？我认为迈克尔说得完全正确。正如你所说，基本
attribution error says that we have access to all of this additional information about our own motivations and about all of the things that we've done that might set us up for success. So, for example, if we put in a lot of hard work and dedication leading up to an eventual payoff, it's really obvious to us all of that work that we put in. And likewise, you know, let's say we put in that same work, but we have bad luck and something happens in our external environment that makes it so that things didn't go the way that we anticipated, that it's much easier for us to see what all of those other things that thwarted us were. Whereas when we're thinking about other people's experiences, we might not see all the behind-the-scenes effort and work that they put in. And we also
归因错误表明，我们能够获取关于自身动机以及所有可能导致我们成功的事情的额外信息。例如，如果我们为最终的回报付出了大量的努力和奉献，那么我们所付出的所有努力对我们来说是非常明显的。同样，假设我们付出了同样的努力，但运气不好，外部环境中发生了一些事情导致事情没有按预期发展，那么我们更容易看到所有阻碍我们的其他因素是什么。然而，当我们思考他人的经历时，我们可能看不到他们付出的所有幕后努力和工作。而且我们
might not be aware of all of the contextual factors that went wrong. And so the idea that Michael is putting forward is really well supported by decades of social psychology research. It's also related to the idea of naive realism, which is that we see the world as it actually is, that we think that we have a sense of objective reality that's correct, and that other people who deviate from that have, you know, all kinds of reasons why they're not able to see things as they actually are. And so then trying to get on the same page is hard. I also want to talk about how when we jump in sometimes with feedback, without paying attention to the contextual factors,
可能没有意识到所有出错的背景因素。因此，迈克尔提出的观点得到了数十年社会心理学研究的有力支持。这也与朴素现实主义的概念有关，即我们认为世界就是它实际的样子，我们认为我们对客观现实有一种正确的感知，而那些偏离这一点的人，你知道，有各种各样的原因导致他们无法看到事物的本来面目。因此，试图达成共识是很困难的。我还想谈谈，当我们有时在不注意背景因素的情况下直接给出反馈时，
in some ways we're not extending the compassion to others that we often demand from them. So in other words, when I criticize my partner for loading the dishwasher wrong, without acknowledging that my partner has actually taken the trouble to actually load the dishwash, or my partner might be tired. And all I'm focusing on is what my partner is doing wrong as opposed to what my partner is doing right. Yes, and that also gets to this point that the social situation is not only unfolding in this exact moment, but is also a product of the history that we have together and of what I
在某种程度上，我们并没有给予他人我们经常要求他们给予我们的那种同情。换句话说，当我批评我的伴侣洗碗机装得不对时，却没有承认我的伴侣实际上已经费心去装洗碗机了，或者我的伴侣可能很累。而我只关注我的伴侣做错了什么，而不是他做对了什么。是的，这也触及了这一点，即社会情境不仅在这一刻展开，而且是我们共同历史的产物，也是我
imagine your intentions to be. and when we get into a situation where we're not extending that grace or compassion to other people, maybe because all of the work or the motivations that they have aren't obvious to us, then things can compound, right? And so, you know, I'll share when my partner, Brett, and I were thinking about getting married, we thought about what our wedding vows should be. And first we had a party where we had a wedding vow bracket, and we let friends nominate what they thought we should vow.
想象中你的意图的产物。当我们进入一种没有给予他人那种宽容或同情的境地时，也许是因为他们所有的努力或动机对我们来说并不明显，那么事情就会变得复杂，对吧？所以，我会分享一下，当我的伴侣布雷特（Brett）和我考虑结婚时，我们思考了我们的结婚誓言应该是什么。首先，我们举办了一个派对，我们有一个结婚誓言的竞选环节，我们让朋友们提名他们认为我们应该许下的誓言。
The winning one was, I vow to treat you like a queen but respect you like a prime minister. And we decided that, you know, although that's funny, it's probably not the formulation to be the foundation for the rest of our lives together. And one of the things that we did vow was that I will assume that you have good intentions. And also on the other side, that basically will earn it, right, that will always try to come into interactions
获胜的誓言是：“我发誓像对待女王一样对待你，但像尊重首相一样尊重你。”我们决定，虽然这很有趣，但这可能不是我们余生共同生活的基础。我们确实许下的誓言之一是：我会假设你怀有善意。另一方面，基本上我们也会赢得这一点，对吧，即我们总是会尝试带着
with good intentions for each other. And so having that kind of base expectation that if somebody's doing something where it seems like they're being a jerk, their behavior makes sense to them. And so trying to understand why what they're doing makes sense to them is so important because we don't have access to it automatically.
对彼此的善意进入互动。因此，拥有那种基本的期望，即如果某人做的事情看起来像个混蛋，那么他们的行为对他们自己来说是有道理的。所以试图理解为什么他们所做的事情对他们来说是有道理的非常重要，因为我们无法自动获取这些信息。
When we come back, ideas on how we can reduce our defensiveness and help others do the same. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. When someone gives us constructive feedback, we often instinctively think, no way, that can't be true. It's psychologically easier to reject criticism than to grapple with a challenge to our sense of self. At the University of Pennsylvania, psychologist Emily Fox studies the scientific. psychology of defensiveness and what we can do about it. Emily, if our attachment to the self is part of the reason we are defensive, you and others
稍后回来，我们将探讨如何减少防御性并帮助他人做到同样点的想法。您正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》（Hidden Brain）。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆（Shankar Vedantam）。这是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。当有人给我们建设性的反馈时，我们往往会本能地认为：“不可能，那不可能是真的。”在心理上，拒绝批评比面对对自我意识的挑战要容易得多。在宾夕法尼亚大学，心理学家艾米丽·福克斯（Emily Fox）研究防御性的科学心理学以及我们能对此做些什么。艾米丽，如果说我们对自我的依恋是我们产生防御性的部分原因，那么你和其他人
have found that we may need to get some distance from ourselves if we want to become less defensive. What do you mean by this? Well, if our sense of self and our sense of value are intertwined, then one of the ways that we can maybe be less defensive or more open to new ideas is by having a chance to, to zoom out and see that our self-worth isn't necessarily tied up in the specific thing that somebody's asking us to change. And there are a lot of different ways that we can get that kind of psychological distance. So one of the ways we can do it is by reflecting on the things that matter the most to us, which psychologists call values affirmation, like really getting in
发现，如果我们想变得不那么防御，我们可能需要与自己保持一些距离。你这是什么意思？嗯，如果我们的自我意识和价值感是交织在一起的，那么我们减少防御性或对新想法更加开放的方法之一，就是有机会退后一步，看到我们的自我价值并不一定与别人要求我们改变的具体事情挂钩。我们可以通过很多不同的方式获得那种心理距离。所以我们可以做的方法之一是反思那些对我们最重要的事情，心理学家称之为“价值观肯定”，比如真正地
touch with the things that are most important, most core to us, which then can offer the perspective that, you know, whether or not I backed into the parking space correctly or loaded the dishwasher the way that you wanted me to doesn't actually determine whether I'm a good person or not, because it's not as fundamental as these other kinds of things, like, you know, friendship or compassion or spirituality. On the other hand, we can also do it more directly by taking a step back and thinking about a perspective of somebody who we think would have a wise response to this situation. So thinking about a role model or another person who we think might be able to respond to the situation in a way that we ideally would like to, both kind of takes us outside
接触那些对我们最重要、最核心的事情，这可以提供一种视角，即：无论我是否正确地倒车入库，或者是否按照你想要的方式装好了洗碗机，实际上并不能决定我是否是一个好人，因为它不像友谊、同情心或灵性这些其他事情那样根本。另一方面，我们也可以通过退后一步，思考一个我们认为会对这种情况做出明智回应的人的视角来更直接地做到这一点。所以思考一个榜样或另一个我们认为能够以我们理想的方式回应这种情况的人，既能让我们跳出
of ourselves. And then there's really fantastic research that Megan Meyer and Diana Tamir did that shows that when we do that mental simulation of somebody else's response to a situation, the way that our brains handle that task, actually that. make us take on some of those qualities. It makes us sort of identify with the characteristics of that wiser or more patient person. Can you talk about some of the other techniques that research has found are very effective when it comes to self-distancing, Emily, including the idea that sometimes it's helpful to imagine how we might feel about the current situation if we were, for example, two years in the future? Yes. So our brains handle different kinds of
我们自己。而且梅根·迈耶（Megan Meyer）和戴安娜·塔米尔（Diana Tamir）所做的非常出色的研究表明，当我们对别人的反应进行心理模拟时，我们大脑处理该任务的方式实际上会让我们吸收其中的一些品质。它让我们认同那个更明智或更有耐心的人的特征。艾米丽，你能谈谈研究发现的在自我疏离方面非常有效的其他技巧吗？包括有时想象如果我们处于未来两年后的情境，我们会有什么感觉，这是否有帮助？是的。所以我们的大脑以类似的方式处理不同种类的
of psychological distance in similar ways, which I think is incredible. So thinking about ourself somewhere far away in time, like two years in the future, somewhere physically removed, somewhere that's geographically distant from where we are, thinking about ourselves as a different person or with different identities, all of those things can create psychological distance. And taking that perspective of a fly on the wall, for example, can help us feel less angry or reduce aggressive thoughts or reactions that might escalate the conflict or have us show up as, you know, not the way that we would want to be. And this is true, interestingly, both in adults and in kids. It's interesting. We heard from a listener named Sue, who is herself a writing professor.
心理距离，我认为这太不可思议了。所以想象自己在时间上很遥远的地方，比如两年后的未来，在物理上远离某个地方，在地理上远离我们所在的地方，把自己想象成一个不同的人或拥有不同的身份，所有这些事情都可以创造心理距离。例如，采取“墙上的苍蝇”的视角，可以帮助我们减少愤怒，或减少可能升级冲突或让我们表现出我们不希望表现出的那种攻击性想法或反应。有趣的是，这在成年人和孩子身上都是如此。很有趣。我们收到了一位名叫苏（Sue）的听众的来信，她本人是一位写作教授。
She had an interesting experience in class after listening to our episode about defensiveness. Sue was teaching a class of graduate students, and I let her pick up a story. from there. I noticed in the crowd one of my former undergrads, and I recognized her. Her name is Desiree. And I said, oh, Desiree, you'll be familiar with all these concepts that I'm talking about. Concrete nouns, active verbs. I won't bore you with the grammar lesson. And then she responded and said, oh yeah, I remember those. And of course, you're all over the place. I remember that about you. And I stood kind of like a deer in the headlights and recognized one of my challenges, and that is to be methodic and linear with my students.
她在听了我们关于防御性的那一集后，在课堂上有过一次有趣的经历。苏当时正在教一个研究生班，我让她从那里讲起。我在人群中注意到我以前的一名本科生，我认出了她。她的名字叫德西蕾（Desiree）。我说：“哦，德西蕾，你会熟悉我正在谈论的所有这些概念。具体名词，主动动词。我就不拿语法课来烦你了。”然后她回应说：“哦，是的，我记得那些。当然，你总是东拉西扯的。我记得你这一点。”我当时就像被车灯照住的鹿一样，意识到我面临的挑战之一，那就是对我的学生要做到有条理和线性。
I am not that way in the world. I'm associative. I jump around. I'm theatrical. I'm eccentric. I'm sure you can tell this already. And in that moment, bless her heart, Desiree called her. me out. But because I had listened to Hidden Brain that morning or the day before, I had an opportunity
我在世界上并不是那样的人。我是联想型的。我跳来跳去。我是戏剧性的。我是古怪的。我相信你已经能看出来了。在那一刻，上帝保佑她，德西蕾指出了这一点。但我因为那天早上或前一天听了《隐藏的大脑》，我有机会
in real time to reframe that experience and use it as a teachable moment. So I stopped the class and what I got to do in this moment with Desiree in front of this class and said, you know, Desiree, I am aspirationally organized, not actually organized. but I try and now you've given me a chance to try again. And in that moment, not only did I humanize myself to these people in the classroom, and not only did I get a big laugh, but I really did get to take a breath and then be a little more methodic. And I sort of did a, okay, let's take it from the top.
实时重构那种体验，并将其作为一个可教的时刻。所以我停下了课，我在课堂上当着大家的面与德西蕾进行了互动，我说：“你知道吗，德西蕾，我是志向上的有条理，而不是实际上的有条理。但我尝试过，现在你给了我一个再次尝试的机会。”在那一刻，我不仅在这些课堂上的人面前人性化了自己，而且不仅引起了一阵大笑，而且我真的得以深呼吸，然后变得更有条理了一些。我做了一个“好吧，让我们从头开始”。
Here's what I'm talking about. It was such a wonderful moment for me. Emily, what does Sue do right here? I love this story so much. And Sue, I'm just so delighted that you are able to do that because what a gift for the students to see that model of somebody who takes a beat and recognizes that everybody has areas to grow and then gets this really positive response, right?
这就是我正在谈论的内容。对我来说，这是一个非常美妙的时刻。艾米丽，苏在这里做对了什么？我非常喜欢这个故事。苏，我很高兴你能做到这一点，因为对于学生来说，看到一个停顿一下并认识到每个人都有成长空间，然后得到这种非常积极回应的榜样，是一份多么好的礼物啊，对吧？
That the students laugh and they're with her. So now Sue and her students are all, on the same team. But I really love that she was open to that feedback. Hmm. One thing I noticed is that after she heard the criticism from her student, Sue took a moment to pause. She didn't react right away. She took a beat to consider what she was hearing and what she was feeling. And in some ways that echoes what you were saying a moment ago, Emily, which is that one key to not getting too defensive is to not react immediately. Yes. I think Sue did herself. and her students of big service by taking that moment to honor what she was feeling,
学生们笑了，他们和她站在一边。所以现在苏和她的学生们都在同一个团队里。但我真的很喜欢她对那个反馈持开放态度。嗯。我注意到的一件事是，在听到学生的批评后，苏停顿了一下。她没有立即反应。她花了一点时间来考虑她所听到的和她所感受到的。在某种程度上，这呼应了你刚才所说的，艾米丽，即不产生过度防御性的一个关键是不要立即反应。是的。我认为苏通过花那一点时间来尊重她的感受，为她自己和她的学生做了很大的贡献，
because of course, it feels hard to hear the things that we might be able to do better at. And in the moment, I completely relate to the idea that we would have that moment of feeling defensive. And she also then was able to take a step back and think about it in context, right? And also the idea that Desre was willing to give that feedback, I think speaks highly of Sue. Because students are in a somewhat vulnerable position. And if they think that you're the kind of person who can't take critique, then I would imagine that they wouldn't give you that feedback in the classroom to begin with. There was also a wonderful moment in this anecdote that Sue narrated where, you know, it started out being. Desiree versus Sue, where Desiree says something, it was perceived as a criticism. I can imagine
因为当然，听到我们可能做得更好的事情感觉很难受。在那一刻，我完全理解我们会有那种感到防御的时刻。而且她随后也能够退后一步，从背景中思考它，对吧？而且德西蕾愿意提供那种反馈的想法，我认为对苏评价很高。因为学生处于某种脆弱的位置。如果他们认为你是那种无法接受批评的人，那么我想他们一开始就不会在课堂上给你那种反馈。在苏讲述的这个轶事中，还有一个美妙的时刻，你知道，它开始时是德西蕾对阵苏，德西蕾说了些什么，这被视为一种批评。我可以想象
students sitting up and asking themselves, how is the professor going to react? But Sue's very wise and mature response put them all, as you said, on the same team. And suddenly it's not, you know, me versus you. It's me and you versus whatever the problem is that we're confronting together. Exactly. And I think that that type of response where somebody has a critique or feedback for us that we can benefit from framing that situation as an opportunity for us to solve the problem together. So when we do performance feedback in my lab, for example, one of the things that helps me a lot is when my team is giving me feedback about how I could be a better boss to have them also offer solutions. So rather than just identifying the problems, when they give me
学生们坐直了身子问自己，教授会怎么反应？但苏非常明智和成熟的回应让他们都像你所说的那样，站在了同一个团队里。突然之间，这不是“我对你”，而是“我和你一起对抗我们共同面临的任何问题”。完全正确。而且我认为那种有人对我们提出批评或反馈，我们可以从中受益，将这种情况视为我们共同解决问题的机会的反应。所以，例如，当我在我的实验室进行绩效反馈时，对我帮助很大的一件事是，当我的团队给我反馈关于我如何能成为一个更好的老板时，让他们也提供解决方案。所以，与其仅仅指出问题，当他们给我
thoughts about how we could solve the issue, how we could work around the thing that is a problem, then it puts us on the same team. And likewise, when I'm trying to give them feedback, not just saying, I need you to do this differently, but also, you know, what are the ways that I can support you to get additional training or for us to rearrange things so that you have the time or the bandwidth and so on. So basically thinking about situations where we're either giving or receiving feedback as opportunities to be on the same team with that person and first establishing that we both want to solve the problem and then assuming that's true, how can we do it together? Some listeners wondered if defensiveness might be triggered or elevated by the specific language
关于我们如何解决问题、如何绕过那个问题的想法时，这让我们站在了同一个团队。同样，当我试图给他们反馈时，不仅仅是说“我需要你以不同的方式做这件事”，而是说“我有什么方法可以支持你获得额外的培训，或者让我们重新安排事情，以便你有时间或带宽等等”。所以基本上，思考我们给予或接受反馈的情况，作为与那个人站在同一个团队的机会，首先确定我们都想解决问题，然后假设这是真的，我们该如何共同完成它？一些听众想知道防御性是否可能被我们使用的特定语言所触发或提升。
that we use. Here's listener, Laura Lee. I have a friend with whom he does not like hearing the word, I'd like to give you some feedback. He would much rather me say, I'd like to share something with you or I've been thinking about this. So I just find it interesting because I would like to hear what the author has to say about the way we word our quote feedback. So Emily, are there ways of phrasing feedback or even describing what it is that we're doing that can reduce defensiveness? Laura Lee's situation is interesting because it sounds like she already has a norm with her friend that they give each other feedback.
这是听众劳拉·李（Laura Lee）。我有一个朋友，他不喜欢听到“我想给你一些反馈”这句话。他更希望我说“我想和你分享一些事情”或“我一直在思考这个问题”。所以我只是觉得这很有趣，因为我想听听作者对于我们措辞“反馈”的方式有什么看法。所以艾米丽，有没有什么措辞反馈甚至描述我们正在做的事情的方式可以减少防御性？劳拉·李的情况很有趣，因为听起来她和她的朋友之间已经有了一种他们互相提供反馈的规范。
And so if she knows this about her friend that there are particular ways that he likes to get feedback, then that seems very valuable to know. Because on her side, the stakes might be pretty low in terms of whether she says, I'd like to give you some feedback versus here's something that I've been thinking about. And so if those words have particular meaning to the person that she's interacting with, then that's really valuable information to have. And so one of the things I take away from Laura Lee's story is this idea that norms matter a lot. So if we're on a team where we never give each other feedback and then all of a sudden I come to you and I say, Shankar, I've got some feedback for you. it might loom very large or really elicit defensiveness in a bigger way than if we have the norm that at the beginning of our meetings, we check in about things that are going well and places where we want to potentially make changes. And so the kind of context setup, I think, is important that Laura Lee's story highlights.
所以如果她了解她的朋友，知道他喜欢以特定的方式获得反馈，那么这似乎是非常有价值的了解。因为在她这边，无论是说“我想给你一些反馈”还是“这是我一直在思考的事情”，风险可能都很低。所以如果这些词对她正在互动的人有特殊的意义，那么这就是非常有价值的信息。所以我从劳拉·李的故事中得到的一点是，规范非常重要。所以如果我们在一个从不互相提供反馈的团队中，然后突然我来到你面前说：“尚卡尔，我有一些反馈给你。”这可能会显得非常严重，或者比我们在会议开始时检查进展顺利的事情以及我们可能想要做出改变的地方的规范相比，更容易引起防御性。所以我认为劳拉·李的故事所强调的背景设定很重要。
And then in terms of the words that we use, there's broader kind of categories, I think, psychologically. So we've talked a lot about how taking a step back, getting some psychological distance can be helpful. And there's a lot of research about how stories help reduce defensiveness. So that's not at the word level, but rather the kind of packaging of information. And both the psychology and neuroscience literature highlight how powerful stories can be in helping people learn lessons or see things from a new perspective without getting defensive. and also the anthropology literature. So, for example, a lot of cultures around the world use stories as a way to give feedback to kids or to other people about how we should behave. Can you talk a moment about why this is effective psychologically?
至于我们使用的词汇，我认为在心理学上有更广泛的类别。我们已经谈了很多关于退后一步、获得一些心理距离如何有帮助。而且有很多关于故事如何帮助减少防御性的研究。所以那不是在词汇层面，而是信息的包装方式。心理学和神经科学文献都强调了故事在帮助人们吸取教训或从新的角度看待事物而不产生防御性方面的强大作用。还有人类学文献。例如，世界各地的许多文化都使用故事作为一种方式来给孩子或其他关于我们应该如何表现的人提供反馈。你能谈谈为什么这在心理上是有效的吗？
Why is it that stories and parables, for example, have such power? So in other words, you go up to someone and say, you know, you really shouldn't be so selfish. You should be more generous with your money. that's likely to provoke defensiveness. But you tell them a story about somebody who's very generous or somebody whose generosity transformed some community and people hear the same story with a completely different mindset. What's going on, Emily?
为什么故事和寓言，例如，具有如此强大的力量？换句话说，你走到某人面前说：“你知道，你不应该那么自私。你应该在金钱上更慷慨。”这很可能会引发防御性。但你给他们讲一个关于一个非常慷慨的人，或者一个慷慨改变了某个社区的人的故事，人们会以完全不同的心态听到同一个故事。发生了什么，艾米丽？
In our brains, stories are processed differently than other kinds of information. So they tap into brain regions that help us think about what other people think and feel, for example. And they seem to circumvent the kind of defensive processes that comes, as you said, if you just directly tell somebody to change their behavior. And we've seen this in lots of different examples. During the COVID pandemic, for example, my team did some research looking at people's willingness to help others in their community
在我们的大脑中，故事的处理方式与其他类型的信息不同。所以它们利用了帮助我们思考别人在想什么和感受什么的大脑区域。而且它们似乎绕过了正如你所说的那样，如果你只是直接告诉某人改变他们的行为所带来的那种防御性过程。我们在许多不同的例子中都看到了这一点。例如，在新冠疫情期间，我的团队做了一些研究，观察人们帮助社区中他人的意愿
or change their behavior. And what we found was that when the same exact information was delivered just in terms of facts, you know, the number of people who are being affected and how frontline health care workers were suffering because of the behaviors that we were engaging in, that landed differently than when the exact same information was delivered through stories, for example, of frontline health workers or people who were incarcerated, people whose circumstances made it so that they couldn't take the kinds of preventative actions for the spread of the virus. And in other neuroscience research that we've done, we found that when we use brain stimulation
或改变他们的行为。我们发现，当完全相同的信息仅仅以事实的形式传递时，你知道，受影响的人数以及一线医护人员因为我们正在从事的行为而遭受的痛苦，这与通过故事传递完全相同的信息时，落差是不同的。例如，一线医护人员或被监禁的人的故事，那些人的处境使得他们无法采取预防病毒传播的行动。在我们所做的其他神经科学研究中，我们发现当我们使用脑刺激
technology that changes the way that people's brains are functioning temporarily, stories are still able to help people understand new ideas and people are able to reason about them in a different way than when the same information is delivered as didactic facts. Right. Right. And in some ways, I think stories might also allow us to see, you know, flaws in ourselves if they're depicted in another character. So in other words, if we're hearing, the story of somebody who's very selfish, for example, even if we might have that same selfishness inside us, it's harder to hear it when that feedback is directed directly at us versus when we hear this about someone else. And that allows us to say, oh, I can see a connection between
技术暂时改变人们大脑运作方式时，故事仍然能够帮助人们理解新想法，并且人们能够以一种与将相同信息作为说教事实传递时不同的方式进行推理。对。对。在某种程度上，我认为故事也可能让我们看到我们自己身上的缺陷，如果它们被描绘在另一个角色身上。换句话说，如果我们听到一个非常自私的人的故事，例如，即使我们内心可能也有同样的自私，当反馈直接针对我们时，比我们听到关于别人的事情时更难接受。这使我们能够说：“哦，我可以看到我表现的方式和这个人表现的方式之间的联系。”
how I'm behaving and how this other person's behaving. Yes, and it also allows us to think about solutions, right? So in a story, you can see what you might want the character to do differently. And without having that immediate defensive response that we sometimes have and we're thinking about our own behavior when we feel bad because we potentially have harmed somebody else, when we see somebody else engaging in a particular set of things that are not in their best interests or aren't kind or aren't the way that you'd actually want to behave if you're being your best self, it's also easier to see, well, what could the person do about it? When we come back, is it always wrong to be defensive? How should we respond to feedback that is inaccurate or unwise? You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. There's an old joke. Just because you're paranoid doesn't mean they aren't after you.
是的，它也让我们思考解决方案，对吧？所以在一个故事中，你可以看到你可能希望角色以不同的方式做什么。而且没有我们在思考自己的行为时有时会有的那种即时防御性反应，当我们因为可能伤害了别人而感到难过时，当我们看到别人从事一系列不符合他们最大利益、不友善或不是你表现出最好自己时想要表现的方式的事情时，也更容易看到：“好吧，那个人能对此做些什么？”稍后回来，防御性总是错的吗？我们应该如何回应不准确或不明智的反馈？您正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。有一个古老的笑话：仅仅因为你多疑，并不意味着他们没有在针对你。
We've seen how defensiveness can keep us from hearing useful feedback and criticism. But does fixing our defensiveness mean that we should always listen to criticism? At the University of Pennsylvania, psychologist Emily Fox studies the psychology of defensiveness and what we can do about it. Emily, there's a layer of complexity that's often involved when it comes to handling feedback. How do we suss out if the person giving us feedback
我们已经看到了防御性如何阻止我们听到有用的反馈和批评。但修复我们的防御性是否意味着我们应该总是听取批评？在宾夕法尼亚大学，心理学家艾米丽·福克斯研究防御性的心理学以及我们能对此做些什么。艾米丽，在处理反馈时，通常涉及一层复杂性。我们如何查明提供反馈的人
has our goals and best interests at heart? Sometimes, of course, the feedback we get isn't designed for our benefit. It's designed for the benefit of the person who's trying to give us the feedback. Here's a question on that front from a listener named Ron. I would like to hear the researchers' thoughts on how one might still be on guard for things like manipulation, for example, gaslighting. It seems to me like someone can use the kind of information laid out in the researchers' talk and apply to somebody who is otherwise very logical.
是否真正关心我们的目标和最大利益？当然，有时我们得到的反馈并不是为了我们的利益而设计的。它是为了试图给我们反馈的人的利益而设计的。这是一位名叫罗恩（Ron）的听众提出的关于这方面的问题。我想听听研究人员对于一个人如何仍然可以防范诸如操纵（例如煤气灯效应）之类的事情的想法。在我看来，有人可以使用研究人员谈话中列出的那种信息，并将其应用于一个本来非常合乎逻辑的人身上。
So how do we take this kind of information and allow ourselves to be more open to constructive criticism at the same? same time protecting ourselves from people who really just want to manipulate us. Thank you. So, Emily, how do we tell the difference between garden variety defensiveness and the potentially useful ability to watch out for manipulation by bad actors? I think that the key distinction here is that taking feedback doesn't necessarily mean believing everything that we hear or acting on it. It's just giving ourselves enough space to consider whether it might be helpful. helpful for us in the first place. So if we're thinking about the situations on average that tend to make people more open to new information or constructive feedback, we see that when people have a
那么我们如何利用这类信息，使自己对建设性批评更加开放，同时保护自己免受那些只想操纵我们的人的伤害？谢谢。所以，艾米丽，我们如何区分普通的防御性和为了防范坏人的操纵而保持警惕的潜在有用能力？我认为这里的关键区别在于，接受反馈并不一定意味着相信我们所听到的一切或据此采取行动。它只是给我们自己足够的空间来考虑它是否可能对我们有帮助。所以如果我们平均思考那些倾向于使人们对新信息或建设性反馈更加开放的情况，我们看到当人们有一个
goal to be accurate or a goal to improve or a goal to solve a particular problem, then they're often more open to what scientists call uncongenial information, like ideas that might challenge. your current beliefs or perspectives or suggest that you do something differently. And so that makes sense that if we have a particular goal and we think that this person's input might help us achieve that particular goal, then we'd be more receptive to it. Now, on the other hand, when somebody gives us unsolicited advice or unsolicited feedback, that's not necessarily starting from our goal. we're just going about our day-to-day life,
准确的目标，或者改进的目标，或者解决特定问题的目标时，他们通常对科学家所说的“不合意信息”更加开放，比如可能挑战你当前信念或观点，或建议你以不同方式做某事的想法。所以如果我们有一个特定的目标，并且我们认为这个人的输入可能有助于我们实现那个特定的目标，那么我们就会更乐于接受它。现在，另一方面，当有人给我们未经请求的建议或未经请求的反馈时，那并不一定是从我们的目标出发的。我们只是在过我们的日常生活，
and this person comes along and proposes a new goal for us, right? And then we can evaluate whether they share our best interests, whether they have some particular motivation that is incompatible with our best interests. And so I say all of that to say that we can focus our attention on things like accuracy motives and on things like whether this is actually compatible with my bigger picture. goals and values, and that that is not necessarily saying that we're being defensive, right? That's being thoughtful. Right. I mean, when someone gives you financial advice, for example, it really is important to actually ask, is this advice coming from a place of vested interest?
然后这个人走过来为我们提出了一个新的目标，对吧？然后我们可以评估他们是否符合我们的最大利益，他们是否有一些与我们的最大利益不相容的特定动机。所以我说所有这些都是为了表达，我们可以将注意力集中在准确性动机以及这是否实际上与我的大局目标和价值观相容的事情上，而这并不一定意味着我们表现得防御，对吧？那是深思熟虑。对。我的意思是，当有人给你财务建议时，例如，询问“这个建议是否来自既得利益的地方”确实很重要。
So in some ways, having a certain amount of cautious skepticism is not a bad idea. Yes. And my friend Jamil Zaki calls this being a hopeful skeptic. So as opposed to being, a cynic where we just think that everybody's out to get us or that people are terrible, that we can demand evidence, that we can ask for things to back up particular claims that somebody's making or behaviors that they're suggesting that we can change and that we can be thoughtful and reflective in how we use that information moving forward. So we can disagree with someone else without being defensive, right? We can be curious about their position. We can learn about what their motivations are, we can even potentially get on the same page about a number of different things
所以在某种程度上，保持一定程度的谨慎怀疑并不是一个坏主意。是的。我的朋友贾米尔·扎基（Jamil Zaki）称之为“充满希望的怀疑者”。所以与愤世嫉俗者不同，我们只是认为每个人都在针对我们或人们很糟糕，我们可以要求证据，我们可以要求东西来支持某人正在提出的特定主张或他们建议我们改变的行为，并且我们可以在如何使用这些信息向前迈进时保持深思熟虑和反思。所以我们可以在不产生防御性的情况下不同意别人的观点，对吧？我们可以对他们的立场感到好奇。我们可以了解他们的动机是什么，我们甚至可能在许多不同的事情上达成共识
without automatically conceding our position or automatically changing what we're doing in our day-to-day life. In most domains of our lives, moderation is important. We had a question from a listener named Isabel about the potential risks of going overboard when it comes to embracing another person's critiques. Here's Isabel. Is there any research or studies or even advice on any runoff feelings of I'm a failure, I'm just sinking into that feedback and criticism that my loved one, partner, friend, family gave me without the defensive border, but just immediately jumping into the kind of failure thought process? So Isabel points out something interesting here, Emily. It seems fairly easy for some people to jump from accepting someone's critical feedback to accepting the message, I'm a failure.
而无需自动让步我们的立场或自动改变我们在日常生活中所做的事情。在我们生活的大多数领域，适度很重要。我们收到了一位名叫伊莎贝尔（Isabel）的听众关于在拥抱他人批评时走极端的潜在风险的问题。这是伊莎贝尔。是否有任何研究或研究，甚至关于“我是个失败者”的后续感受的建议，我只是沉浸在我的爱人、伴侣、朋友、家人给我的反馈和批评中，没有防御边界，但只是立即跳入那种失败的思维过程？所以伊莎贝尔在这里指出了一个有趣的事情，艾米丽。对于一些人来说，从接受某人的批评性反馈到接受“我是一个失败者”的信息似乎相当容易。
How can we accept the criticism that comes our way without letting it affect our self-esteem? I think that Isabel's question and comment highlight something that's really important about the ways that we take feedback on board for things that might be very important. to us versus things that might be less important to us. So research from Brent Hughes's lab has looked at the way that we construct our sense of self. And there's kind of a hierarchy of traits where some of them are much more core to our sense of who we are, maybe thinking about the ways that we're kind or honest or loyal to our friends and family. Those things might be more core. And other kinds of things might be more peripheral, the things that are more specific or less of the most important values to us. And in his team's research, what they found is that when people were given
我们如何才能接受我们遇到的批评而不让它影响我们的自尊？我认为伊莎贝尔的问题和评论强调了关于我们如何为那些可能对我们非常重要的事情吸收反馈的方式的一些重要内容，与那些可能对我们不太重要的事情相比。来自布伦特·休斯（Brent Hughes）实验室的研究观察了我们构建自我意识的方式。有一种特质的等级制度，其中一些对我们是谁的意识更核心，也许思考我们如何善良、诚实或对朋友和家人忠诚。那些事情可能更核心。而其他类型的事情可能更边缘，那些更具体或对我们来说不是最重要的价值观的事情。在他的团队的研究中，他们发现当人们被给予
feedback about their performance on a particular task from supposedly a group of experts, first, people were much quicker to take on board the positive feedback than the negative feedback. So when they said, wow, this person looks like they're really smart or this person looks like they're really funny or really engaging, then that's easier to say, wow, I didn't think of myself as somebody who is a particularly engaging speaker, but I guess if this audience thinks I am, if this set of evaluators thinks I am, then that must be true. And on average, for the typical person in the study, they were a little bit more hesitant to take on board that negative input. So that was particularly true for people who came into the study with higher self-esteem and lower levels of depression. And so, you know, Isabelle's story makes me think a little bit about some of those base differences in how we're navigating our day-to-day lives, where if we're finding that it's very easy for us to absorb other people's negative evaluations, that might be a situation where we want to,
关于他们在特定任务上的表现的反馈，据说是来自一组专家，首先，人们吸收正面反馈的速度比负面反馈快得多。所以当他们说“哇，这个人看起来真的很聪明”或“这个人看起来真的很风趣或很有吸引力”时，那么说“哇，我没把自己想成一个特别有吸引力的演讲者，但我想如果这个听众认为我是，如果这组评估者认为我是，那么那一定是真的”就更容易了。而且平均而言，对于研究中的典型人来说，他们对吸收那种负面输入稍微犹豫了一些。所以这对于那些带着更高自尊和更低抑郁水平进入研究的人来说尤其如此。所以，你知道，伊莎贝尔的故事让我想起了一些关于我们如何驾驭日常生活的那些基本差异，如果我们发现我们很容易吸收别人的负面评价，那可能是一个我们想要的情况，
take a step back and figure out if we could get some support to bolster our own sense of self, our own sense of self-esteem and well-being, because that could be a flag. We heard from a listener named Soma, who's a writer. Soma says that at times she has struggled to accept suggestions from editors. She knows that they are there to help her, but she also feels attached to what she has written. But one day she got this tip from a friend who was going through an illness. I had a friend who had non-Hodgkin's lymphoma and some other health, serious health complications, who has since passed.
退后一步，看看我们是否能获得一些支持，以增强我们的自我意识、自尊心和幸福感，因为这可能是一个信号。我们收到了一位名叫Soma的听众的来信，她是一位作家。Soma说，有时她很难接受编辑的建议。她知道他们是为了帮助她，但她也对自己写的东西有感情。但有一天，她从一位正在经历疾病的朋友那里得到了这个建议。我有一位朋友患有非霍奇金淋巴瘤和其他一些严重的健康并发症，她后来去世了。
And how did she stand all the pain, keep going through the treatments, the moods that they caused? She said, well, it's all just weather. And, you know, it's like a cloudy day. You know, it's going to rain. And you just accept it. You don't get mad at the sky for like the weather. You don't get furious that the rain is making you wet. You just find your way through it, knowing that after rain is sunshine and dry weather.
她是如何忍受所有的痛苦，坚持完成治疗，以及治疗引起的情绪波动的呢？她说，嗯，这一切都只是天气。你知道，就像阴天一样。你知道，天会下雨。你只需要接受它。你不会因为天气而对天空生气。你不会因为雨水淋湿了你而愤怒。你只是找到应对的方法，因为你知道雨后会有阳光和干燥的天气。
And so that's what I've tried to do in much less serious situations than, you know, health complications, including getting defensive, initially defensive when someone gives me edits. I just know that that's part of the weather of writing and that whether, changes. I hope that's useful. So while we're not all writers or artists, Emily, I think there's something powerful in what Soma is saying. We're all going to get feedback and criticism at various points in our lives. Can being more philosophical about it help us to absorb it better? What Soma's describing sounds a lot to me like mindfulness. So the idea that we can notice what's happening, kind of like we notice the weather, and that we can accept.
所以，这就是我在比健康并发症严重程度低得多的情况下尝试做的事情，包括在别人给我修改意见时产生防御心理，最初的防御心理。我只是知道这是写作天气的一部分，而天气是会变化的。希望这有帮助。所以，虽然我们不都是作家或艺术家，Emily，我认为Soma所说的话中蕴含着某种强大的力量。我们一生中都会在不同阶段收到反馈和批评。以更哲学的方式对待它能帮助我们更好地吸收它吗？Soma所描述的听起来很像正念。即我们可以注意到正在发生的事情，就像我们注意到天气一样，并且我们可以接受。
it in a non-reactive way or even with a somewhat distanced perspective like we've been talking about. And Soma's friend's experience of navigating terminal diagnosis and illness is a really beautiful story and I'm so sorry to hear that Soma lost her friend. And it also makes me think about my dear friend, Emil Bruno, who ran Penn's Peace and Conflict neuroscience lab. And he got a diagnosis seven years ago about of a glioblastoma brain tumor. And so he understood that that meant that there was really a finite amount of time, typically when people have this kind of brain cancer, they have a fairly short amount of time to live. And in that context, you know, the little things, the things that might be frustrating or annoying or whatever on a day-to-day basis,
以一种非反应性的方式，甚至像我们一直在谈论的那样，带着一种稍微疏离的视角去接受它。Soma朋友在应对绝症和疾病方面的经历是一个非常美丽的故事，听到Soma失去了她的朋友，我感到非常难过。这也让我想起了我亲爱的朋友Emil Bruno，他曾负责宾夕法尼亚大学的和平与冲突神经科学实验室。七年前，他被诊断出患有胶质母细胞瘤脑肿瘤。他明白这意味着时间确实是有限的，通常人们患有这种脑癌时，剩下的生命时间相当短。在这种背景下，你知道，那些日常生活中可能令人沮丧或烦恼的小事，
would just roll off his back in a totally different way. And he reflected on that, like, how that diagnosis and that opportunity to pay attention to the fact that we have a finite number of days and minutes and hours together really put a fine point on the things that really matter and the things that don't. And he really let go of so much defensiveness and became an even more open version of himself in such a beautiful way. And so, you know, I really love Soma's story because I think it also speaks to the ways that when we see other people go through those kinds of experiences with grace, it can also model for us ways that we might move through the world in a slightly less defensive or slightly more open way and then have those effects on other people as well because that kind of way of being is contagious. Emily Falk is a psychologist at the University of Pennsylvania. She's the author of What We Value, the Neuroscience of Choice and Change. Emily, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thanks for having me back, Shankar.
都会以一种完全不同的方式从他身上滑过。他反思了这一点，比如，那种诊断以及关注我们在一起的时间是有限的这一事实的机会，确实让他明确了哪些事情真正重要，哪些不重要。他真的放下了很多防御心理，以一种如此美丽的方式成为了一个更加开放的自己。所以，你知道，我真的很喜欢Soma的故事，因为我认为它也说明了当我们看到其他人以优雅的方式经历这些体验时，它也可以为我们树立榜样，让我们以一种稍微不那么防御或稍微更开放的方式在世界上行走，从而对其他人也产生影响，因为那种存在方式是会传染的。Emily Falk是宾夕法尼亚大学的心理学家。她是《我们重视什么：选择与改变的神经科学》一书的作者。Emily，非常感谢你今天参加Hidden Brain节目。谢谢你再次邀请我，Shankar。
Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Querell, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, Andrew Chadwick, and Nick Woodbury. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. If you like this episode, please take a moment and think of someone else who might benefit from hearing it. Do you have a friend or a partner or a co-worker who struggles with feedback? Please share this episode with two or three people you know.
Hidden Brain由Hidden Brain Media制作。我们的音频制作团队包括Annie Murphy-Paul、Kristen Wong、Laura Querell、Ryan Katz、Autumn Barnes、Andrew Chadwick和Nick Woodbury。Tara Boyle是我们的执行制片人。我是Hidden Brain的执行编辑。如果你喜欢这一集，请花点时间想一想还有谁可能从收听中受益。你是否有朋友、伴侣或同事在面对反馈时感到挣扎？请与你认识的两三个人分享这一集。
Word of mouth recommendations are the way most people find themselves to our show. I'm Shankar Vedantham. See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
口碑推荐是大多数人发现我们节目的方式。我是Shankar Vedantham。再见。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。